[Music]
rebuild our houses and cities
we clear land mines
[Music]
so life
we bring light back into every house
thank you
and build new Bridges
[Music]
in spite of everything
we love and dream
we fight we transform
and work for Ukraine
we are rebuilding better and Greener
using the best of Ukrainian and Global
Innovation and every day we look to our
future with pride and confidence United
in defense United in recovery we build
Ukraine
please welcome the white honorable James
cleverly MP Secretary of State for
foreign Commonwealth and development
Affairs and the Metro culeba Minister of
Foreign Affairs of Ukraine
ladies and gentlemen welcome there are
over 1 000 public and private sector
decision makers here
governments representing 61 States
33 International organizations over 400
businesses and
130 Civil Society organizations after
nearly 18 months of Ukraine withstanding
Russian full-scale invasion the
International Community is coming
together today with a shared belief and
confidence in Ukraine's future
Russia's full-scale Invasion has caused
Untold suffering
but Ukraine is rebuilding now
recovery offers an opportunity not only
to repair what was lost
but to stride forward and to rebuild an
economy that is more modern more open
Greener and more resilient
when I visited Kiev recently I could see
the construction equipment the jcb's
already visible everywhere
this you all see is about unlocking
Ukraine's potential
supporting Ukraine's immediate recovery
needs and unlocking a private sector-led
recovery
after the sacrifices and suffering of
the war
ukrainians are planning for a better
future
and it is in the interests of the world
that that country
the one that they rebuild should be
stronger than ever integrated into
Global markets and self-reliant
so ladies and Gentlemen please join me
in welcoming to the stage my prime
minister Rishi sunak thank you
foreign
[Applause]
good morning and welcome to the Ukraine
recovery conference
now before this terrible War Ukraine's
economy was becoming a huge investment
opportunity
it was the Bread Basket of Europe
exporting millions of tons of food and
grain each month
a top five exporter of Ireland ore and
steel a leader in energy pushing forward
Renewables hydrogen and electric
vehicles and a startup Nation
which helped spark names like PayPal
WhatsApp and revolut with a thriving
Tech sector which actually had a record
year in 2022
because the truth is that opportunity is
still there today
in fact the war has only proved how much
Ukraine has to offer
when I visited Kiev last November I saw
this for myself
I saw Ukraine's incredible spirit
a spirit yes of strength and defiance
but also of Ingenuity and innovation
in a converted office block I met Tech
experts civilian and Military who were
working together to find new ways to
bolster the country's defenses
they were networking mobile phones so
that people across Ukraine could
download an app which would allow their
phone to pick up the sound of the Shahid
drones and feed back the location so
that Ukrainian air defense could track
them and shoot them down
during the winter
Russia tried to destroy Ukraine's energy
grid
by February over 40 percent of power
generation was down
but now because of that incredible
Ingenuity and Defiance Ukraine has got
the grid back online and they're even
able to start exporting electricity back
to Europe
as we've seen in Batman and maripole
what Russia cannot take it will seek to
destroy
they want to do the same to Ukraine's
economy
and the scale of the challenge is real
the war brought a 29 fall in Ukraine's
GDP last year
but just look at the streets of Kiev
despite the threat of attack people are
getting on with their lives and getting
on with business
zelenski's government is determined to
drive reforms to become more open more
transparent and ready for investment
this is a vibrant Dynamic creative
European country that refuses to be
subdued
so together with our allies we will
maintain our support for Ukraine's
defense and for the counter-offensive
we will stand with Ukraine for as long
as it takes for them to continue and to
win this war
we'll also stand with them as they win
the peace
and harness all of that Ingenuity and
Defiance to build the future that they
deserve
the question for us today
is what can we do to support this
to Fast Track recovery and help Ukraine
unleash its potential
it's clear Russia must pay for the
destruction that they've inflicted so
we're working with allies to explore
lawful routes to use Russian assets
and on Monday we publish new legislation
to allow us to keep sanctions in place
until Russia pays up
but beyond that we must bring to bear a
partnership of governments International
financial institutions and Business
Leaders all of us here today to make
this happen
the British government will continue to
play its full part and I'm proud that
today we're announcing a multi-year
commitment to support Ukraine's economy
over three years we will provide loan
guarantees worth three billion dollars
we're also launching a new UK Ukraine
Tech bridge to Foster investment and
talent along with support for green
energy and more all part of a fast
Collective effort from allies and
partners around the world including
significant new support from the EU
which is also being announced this week
financial institutions are playing their
part the IMF is putting 15 billion
dollars into Ukraine over the next four
years as part of a 115 billion dollar
commitment by the G7 and its partners
and institutions like the ebrd are
providing seed Capital to support
private sector-led growth
because above all we must build a
platform for business only they can
truly crowd in The Innovation and
investment that Ukraine needs
and that's why we're launching the
Ukraine business combat for the private
sector to pledge their support for
Ukraine's recovery and reconstruction
and I am delighted to announce today
that over 400 businesses from 38
countries with a combined market cap of
4.9 trillion dollars have now signed up
well the city of London has a huge
amount to offer in their deep and liquid
Capital markets and world-class Finance
expertise
so there is no better place to announce
today the New London conference
framework for war Risk insurance
this is a huge step forward towards
helping insurers to underwrite
investments into Ukraine removing one of
the biggest barriers and giving
investors the confidence they need to
act
with this and everything that we do here
we are sending a message
that our support on the battlefield and
Beyond cannot be outlasted and that
Ukraine's incredible spirit will prevail
now in a moment I'll hand over to my
friend president zielinski but first I'd
just like to share something that I
heard recently
it's about a Ukrainian Soldier fighting
to defend bakmut
he was stationed in an empty house
not far from the front line
surrounded by the destruction of War
when he could snatch a moment of free
time
he used it to plant seeds
he was trying to create a plot of
vegetables hoping
that by the time the homeowners returned
they would have begun to grow
what a profound expression of Hope
and you know from that house to this
Hall we're doing the same thing
we're planting the seeds of Ukraine's
future
today we can water them and in time the
Ukrainian people will harvest them and
now it is my great pleasure to introduce
President zielinski Vladimir you have
the floor
thank you so much
thank you
I just see norishi Mr Prime Minister
thank you for your kind words about
Ukraine about our soldiers and thanks
for your leadership as you were a UK for
us to Ukraine
thank you that's we are really United in
the family freedom
dear layers of politics business and
other opinion Dear Presidents Prime
Ministers ministers second years sales
and head of international organizations
and of course dear Torres
when we are talking about recovering we
are talking about millions of jewels
buildings in covering profits and
freelance of gdps and not only foreign
any
predatory and business of various
students whose brings are poisoned by
dreams of War
growth is always based on that it's just
a song
that rules
um
[Applause]
foreign
disease
task
and I want to thank you
France Italy every country where we have
agreed on key principles who recover
at this conference we must move from
Vision to agreements and from agreements
to real projects
there is a Ukrainian delegation in
London that will present concrete things
that we propose to do together in my
tour I will outline five directions in
which we have begun to create
foundations for peace the first
the first is the potential of unity the
second is the potential of stability the
sewer is rules potential the force is
security potential and the first
extremely important in the potential of
divorce so before we are stressing Unity
Ukraine has already succeeded in making
the EU as United as it has never been
before this is truly a Unity of wealth
which is
reflected
economic session and humanitarian
decisions Ukraine has activities of all
the power of solidarity for which the EU
was conceived and Ukraine is also
explaining the moral force of NATO this
is important for all of us well done
with the world see now does it recognize
native moral leadership
this is only possible with Ukraine in
their alive
[Music]
in fact
just as Ukraine is already part of the
eu's Common Market and on its way to
full membership we already defending the
common States
and are only waiting for the cars for
the airline sneakers to recognize this
really reality politicality
for democracy
videos
we build our analysis and thus we are
still regarding the development freedom
to which our people are used to
to Second
at least 600 million consumers around
the world
this is a huge potential for food
security
at the tops of these poor when the
Russia lost our Wars and destroyed
freedom of the division in the black and
Associates the world so what Ukrainian
brain is
social collapse into different countries
restoring that movement of our
agricultural Problem by sea through two
expert initiatives and this is
sustainability for a huge social and
economic space from Miracle to Somalia
from China to the land from today to
India from state to Pakistan different
aspects different universities but
always a contribution to civility
[Applause]
[Music]
such as
Europe
[Music]
that potential of this interested along
in about 400 billion dollars we build
Agricultural and energy facilities in
Ukraine and thus we are protecting the
wall from cash
foreign
[Music]
what does all this mean
in Ukraine
there is the largest source of economic
industrial and
in Europe for decades and indicates and
by the way this is the only
reconstruction
for example degree transformation of
energy
stimulates the development of Industries
such as Supreme hematology
thanks to this natural resources and
Industrial Traditions Ukraine can become
one of the key Global standards
in addition we have significant
resources of critical resources for the
modern economies such as lithium showed
by by building with Ukraine and in
Ukraine we have our conference and our
conference companies from recessions
forced oil we stressing security of
course this war demonstrates what it
effective defense against impression in
the modern world mirrors are needed and
to what extent more infrastructure is
collecting and what production
about systems make it possible to make
science fiction a reality on the
battlefield
from that from the production of combat
drones to Conventional artillery from a
linear Shield that covers entire country
or even a religion to to shutters in
every school from infrastructure that is
built so that it cannot be destroyed by
the Iranian strategies to cyberspace
that remains resilient even in the in
the face of constant cyber attacks we
are doing we are doing all this in
Ukraine and we need we need the
experience of our partners in all of
these we build security together
the world that developers is
and finally the finished Point democracy
not only to seal Our Land Resources
there can be no Russian Empire
because democracy believes the way
foreign
[Music]
but we all have to realize that the more
democracy we have the greater is special
in our entire reach the more rule of law
we have the more law will work here on
the decisions
even
Russia's full-scale immigration has not
so our internal reinforce Ukraine will
be associated with a fair
[Music]
and a citizen or a company
all public services can and will be
transferred online from business
registration or social assistance to any
any other public service and we are
already exporting our
digitalization tool are the regions are
the conference we have started such
collaboration which is estonians
I'm sure that this is just at the
beginning please be sure to ask our team
our governance officials for more
details about this and this is truly an
example of social progress through
technology
um
even before February 24th we started it
uh dismantling they all only got a model
of economic relations from the Soviet
Union and this is not just something
about the personalities of the polygons
and this is all changing their approach
to economic relations
now
we build institutions and continue
reports in Ukraine and us when defending
democracy and pursuing a call for all at
least in our region
will prevail
during that lifetime of Our Generation
and after us
[Music]
all of you
to Ukraine and by the way prime minister
Russia we we
cannot see each other and keep foreign
thank you for your attention thank you
for your simple world thank you
[Applause]
thank you thank you Vladimir not least
for providing options for my summer
holiday uh in a couple of months but I
uh I know I speak for everyone here when
I say we are with you it's not just
morally right that Ukraine wins this
fight for freedom and democracy but it's
in everyone's interest that you do so as
well and that your economy truly thrives
and we are going to help make that a
reality so thank you again thank you to
everyone who's here today for your
support I know this is going to be a
fantastic conference because we are
going to make a difference we are going
to make it count and now it is my
enormous pleasure to introduce someone
who has shown tremendous leadership on
this issue from the very start the
president of the EU commission my friend
Ursula vonderlein
foreign
presidents Prime Ministers ministers
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
what an inspiring speech and indeed such
an inspiring speech and
hope raising speech against the backdrop
that every day we see the devastation
brought by Russia to Ukraine
the people of Ukraine are enduring every
horror from every direction from the sky
fire Reigns
from the ground they watched that town
sink underwater
Russia fires missiles at innocent
civilians
for no other region reason than one
man's delusional attempt
to restore a Lost Empire
but every day we see also something else
and that is what I witnessed firsthand
when I last visited the country just
over months ago I saw a country that
does everything possible to Rise From
the Ashes of the war
everyday ukrainians show us what they
are fighting for and what they are dying
for
they show it on the battlefield
they show it on their streets
they show it in the classrooms
they are fighting for their future
for Ukraine free from Russian Invaders
for Ukraine that decides its own destiny
for Ukraine rebuilt and revitalized
in just over a year
ukrainians have cleared rubble from 2
000 kilometers of Roads
we built over 40 Bridges
renewed 900 train stations and they pose
and all of this while fighting a war for
their own Survival
but ukrainians are not just restoring
what used to be
they show us how they already reshaping
their country
ukrainians are re-imagining their future
amidst all the lust the pain and the
suffering
let me tell you about European School
number 17.
shrapnel damaged the school's roof
destroyed its walls broke all its
windows and destroyed the heating system
and so when children came back to their
lessons
they did so in unimaginable cold until
a local NGO stepped in with a simple and
creative solution
they installed solar panels on the roof
so children could learn in warmth
this small but meaningful use of clean
energy
to revitalize everyday life
is just one example of how Ukraine is
not just rebuilding but re-imagining
itself
Ukraine has stunned us with a bravery
they have inspired us with ingenuity
and they have ordered us
with the way they are transforming their
country in pursuit of their dream
and dear friends it is this stream
of a cleaner Greener more modern Ukraine
that will be the lasting Legacy of this
atrocious War
and it is our responsibility to make it
happen
because ukrainians are fighting not just
for their sovereignty
but we've just heard it also for us
for our values
for our freedom
for our democracies
we can never match their sacrifice
but we can
we do all Stand United coordinated and
resolute
that Ukraine must win will win and has
our support
not just for as long as it takes to
secure peace
but for a country they are imagining a
country that attracts foreign investment
a country that is master of its future
a country that is a member of the
European Union
together
we will support Ukraine not as
individual Nations but as a coordinated
Community
organized under Innovative platform
a platform that will Channel support to
the reforms and priorities that will
make imagination reality
Together We Get Together We Gather here
to tell ukrainians that their dream is
also our dream
in January we all created the so-called
multi-agency donor coordination platform
it is a first of its kind in the history
of international Aid
it brings together Ukraine
the G7
the European Union the European
Investment Bank the European bank for
reconstruction and development
the IMF and the World Bank
it creates a single focal point for
international donors
to guarantee that support goes exactly
where Ukraine needs it most
the European Commissioners contributing
18 billion euros already this year
and together with other donors we closed
ukrainians budget gap for 2023. so that
Ukraine can continue to pay salaries
pensions and for example for their
health care
this is for Ukraine's immediate needs
but let's talk about the future
I believe the European Union has a
special responsibility
and the reason is simple we heard the
president
ukrainians tell us that when they
imagine their future
they see Europe's flag flying over their
cities
and I have no doubt that Ukraine will be
part of our Union
so today
I want to announce two new steps
the first is about Ukraine's reforms and
its path towards EU membership
despite the war Ukraine has accelerated
its reform agenda with impressive speed
and resolve
we in the European Union want to match
efforts and dedication
and this is why today the European
commission presents a new oral update on
the progress Ukraine made on Judiciary
form on anti-corruption on new laws for
media freedom and international
minorities for example with these
reforms
Ukraine also sends a powerful message to
private investors
they will get the transparency
the fairness and the functioning
institutions they need to invest in
Ukraine
and this is especially important because
we need the private sector to step into
because it is you the private sector
with your invaluable expertise and your
financial Firepower that will help
Ukraine realize its dreams
you're here today at this conference and
we really need you and we know we can
rely on you
and that brings me to my last point
we want to match Ukrainian reforms with
European Investments
for every step Ukraine takes towards us
the European Union must take a step
towards Ukraine
yesterday
the European commission proposed to
create a new facility for Ukraine
within the budget of the European Union
it will ensure constant financial
support till 2027.
the facility will be financed in three
ways
with grants from the European budget
with loans raised on Capital markets
and eventually with proceeds from the
immobilized Russian assets
we will come with a proposal for these
assets before the summer break because
the perpetrator has to be held
accountable
now what are the estimated needs
until 2027
Ukraine's remaining fiscal Gap is about
60 billion euros
the needs for fast recovery on top
are about 50 billion euros
that makes in total
110 billion euros until 2027 that are
not covered
therefore yesterday I proposed to EU
member states
to cover 45 percent of this Gap this is
in total 50 billion euros for Ukraine
and we will work with Ukraine on a
corresponding plan and we heard the
first outlines of the planet more
details will come today for Investments
and reform
this plan could become an anchor for all
International donors including the
private sector you need predictability
you need Clarity you need transparency
this will help our coordination and will
maximize our impact and this is what I
mean when we say we are with Ukraine for
as long as it takes
ladies and gentlemen
put in shattered peace on our continent
on February 24th in 2022
but he triggered also Ukraine's Journey
towards its dream
and it's our job
and our duty
to the ukrainians who've paid the
ultimate sacrifice
that we unsure
that this re-imagined future becomes
reality
Brick by Brick
house by house
school by school
together we are by Ukraine's site for
the Long Haul Slava Ukraine
well hello everybody and as you all know
nearly 16 months ago Russian troops
launched a brutal Invasion that has
brought Terror Bloodshed and anguish to
Ukraine and to its people
Russia's actions are not only a vicious
assault on a Sovereign Nation determined
to choose his own path they're also an
attack on the international
rule-based order that is underpinned so
much of Humanity's progress since the
end of the second World War
early on I let my voice Ukraine's fight
with sovereignty and self-determination
I've done this because their struggle is
ours too
the alternative to a pre and Democratic
Ukraine is an increasingly illiberal and
insular world
a world without Justice a world without
equality or the rule of law
a well-devoyed of human decency and
Humanity
I'm sure you agree that it's the very
antithesis to a world any of us would
want to live in
in the last 12 months I've had the
privilege of visiting Ukraine twice
meeting not only president zelinski but
also countless Brave ukrainians
many shared harrowing and moving stories
of Devastation and suffering and loss
and yet I've also learned so much about
ukrainian's courage and resilience and
the unbreakable Spirit at the heart of
their fight for survival
I have more help than ever that this
fight can and will be won
we'll have to see what the coming weeks
and months hold but the continued
support of Ukraine's allies has been
making a difference and I hope this
support will remain unwavering until the
last Russian troops leave Ukraine's
Sovereign territory from donbass to
Crimea
today I thank all of you have come to
London to discuss what Ukraine's
recovery might look like
but more importantly 44 million
ukrainians a quarter of them now
refugees are internally displaced
look to this conference in anticipation
their hopes and aspirations are really
not different from those most of us hold
dear to live in peace and free from
repression to see their families friends
and communities flourish to find
opportunity perhaps even to start a
business
that's the humanity behind every figure
and every statistic
and we must never forget that this is
why we are here
business will be Central to this effort
to begin we must continue to speak up
for Ukraine and against the aggressor
I'm encouraged that so many Business
Leaders have stepped forward and done
that
I've held deeply honored when President
silencio asked me to serve as an
ambassador to his initiative United 24
and will do what I can to be a voice for
Ukraine and it's amazing people
sadly there is an unacceptably large
number of businesses that continue to do
business in and with Russia contributing
significantly to Putin's War chess
sanctions must be tightened loopholes
closed and violations punished I really
hope that governments will find answers
to these challenges there will be no
recovery without peace and for Ukraine
to win the peace business must not stand
in its way
many of us supporting Ukraine welcome UK
government's initiative to launch a
business compact for Ukraine and I'm
proud that the Virgin group is among the
first companies to sign on
Ukraine needs a sustained Collective
commitment across all sectors to help
rebuild its infrastructure in its
battered towns and to bring its economy
back on its feet
the World Bank estimates that Ukraine's
recovery will require at least 400
billion over the next 10 years
some may call this the cost of fixing
things I'd like to think of it as a
smart investment in Ukraine's future
that will power Innovation and green
growth led by the skilled talent and
determination of Ukraine's
entrepreneurial people
many of us stand ready to do our part
and I urge you all to do yours and
create an enabling environment so that
Ukraine can build back better
a thriving prosperous Ukraine is our
best hope for peace and stability in the
region and Beyond your support and your
commitments will make all the difference
in this spirit I wish all of your most
productive conference cheers thank you
[Applause]
I think if if you did raise a glass of
whiskey it would be even more a more
strong a stronger message
but Richard is a good friend of Ukraine
he has been to to keep many times
um
as our brave soldiers are on the
counter-offensive against Russian army
in Ukraine
we are
launching a counter-offensive against
destruction caused by the Russian army
in Ukraine
and I would like to thank all of you for
Gathering here
we're not starting from scratch as
president zielinski said time has come
to move from Visions to agreements and
this is why we attach great importance
specifically to this event in London
and as we are about to begin the part of
the conference
led by my colleagues and Friends foreign
ministers I would like to thank all of
them personally and their governments
they represent
for their leadership
commitment
and through friendship in helping
Ukraine
mitigate the consequences of the
disaster caused by the Russian
aggression and damage inflicted not only
on us but in Europe as a whole and
euro-atlantic space as a whole
thank you and we are looking forward to
very productive discussions here in
London
[Applause]
uh thanks my good friend Dimitri and now
could I invite my fellow foreign
ministers to the stage Anthony blinken
the U.S Secretary of State alakaris the
president of Estonia
christianis carrots the Prime Minister
of Latvia Antonia Tiani foreign minister
Deputy Prime Minister of Italy and Elena
Federal Minister of Foreign Affairs of
Germany
yoshimasu Hayashi foreign minister of
Japan Catherine colonar foreign minister
of France it's a big narrow foreign
minister of Poland and harjit sajan
Minister for International Development
of Canada
and can I invite first to speak Anthony
blink in U.S Secretary of State thank
you
thank you
good morning everyone
prime minister schmel
thank you for bringing us together
and bringing together such a broad and
diverse Coalition of governments
businesses International financial
institutions
Civil Society groups all dedicated to
Ukraine's recovery
as President Biden said since Russia
launched its full-scale invasion of
Ukraine
the United States will stand with
Ukraine for as long as it takes
and that includes being by Ukraine's
side as it recovers from this
catastrophic Russian aggression
it's uh
easy sometimes
to be a little numbed
by what is going on day in day out in
Ukraine
we see the images flashed by on our TV
screens
we talk about the numbers
and sometimes what's get what gets lost
is the day in day out human devastation
that Russia is inflicting on Ukraine
and I think it's so important
that even as We Gather here today to
talk in detail
about what all of us are doing together
with Ukraine to help it recover we never
lose sight
of that human Dimension because at the
end of the day that's what it's all
about
back in April just one day
in this devastating aggression
in the city of Oman
hundreds of miles from the front lines
another assault
of Russian missiles
on innocent Ukrainian civilians on
apartment buildings hundreds of miles
away
in one of those buildings Before Dawn
a Russian missile struck
the father dimitro and his apartment
raced to his children's room
he opened the door to the room
to try to see
how his children Carrillo 17 and Sophia
11. we're doing he opened the door to
the room
it wasn't there anymore
his children were gone
two of the six children killed that one
day that one day in April
as a result of this ongoing aggression
against Ukraine
two of thousands
killed through the course of this war
two lives interrupted two stories
stopped
that's what this is about every day
but
as Russia continues to destroy we are
here to help Ukraine rebuild
rebuild lives rebuild its country
rebuild its future
recovery is about more than just
ensuring people have what they need to
survive
food to eat water to drink medicine to
take
heat in the winter electricity in All
Seasons we're recovery is about laying
the foundation for Ukraine to thrive
as a secure independent country fully
integrated with Europe connected to
markets around the world
a democracy rooted in the rule of law a
place where all ukrainians have dignity
human rights the opportunity to reach
their full potential
every investment that we make in
Ukraine's recovery is aimed at bringing
ukrainians closer to that reality
and today I'm announcing that with the
support of the United States Congress we
will provide more than 1.3 billion
dollars in additional Aid to help
Ukraine toward that goal
we're going to invest over 520 million
dollars to help Ukraine overhaul its
energy grid
more than half of which as you've heard
has been destroyed by Russia
and in so doing make it cleaner make it
more resilient make it more integrated
with Europe
and will support Ukraine's energy Market
reforms
to combat monopolies and to Spur more
private investment which will enable
Ukraine one day to become a major energy
exporter
this support will complement the work
that's already being done by the G7 plus
coordination Group which we launched
last October and of co-led ever since
first with Germany now with Japan
that group is going to include 18
countries and several multilateral
institutions together we've allocated
billions of dollars to help repair and
rebuild Ukraine's energy sector we sent
more than 5 million power generators to
Ukraine Transformers cables pipe circuit
breakers other pieces of energy
equipment
the United States will also provide
657 million dollars to help modernize
Ukraine's border crossings its Rail
lines its ports other critical
infrastructure
that connect the country with Europe
allowing it to exchange more Goods buy
more Pathways more and more efficiently
we'll direct an additional 100 million
dollars toward digitizing Ukraine's
customs and other systems
to boost speed and to cut corruption
and will commit 35 million dollars to
help Ukrainian businesses and
entrepreneurs through financing and
insurance that reduces risks for
investors in Ukraine
this new support that I'm announcing
today comes on top of more than 20
billion dollars that the United States
has provided an Economic and Development
assistance to Ukraine's workers as
businesses it's public services to help
them endure the 16 months of punishing
conflict with unwavering bipartisan
support from our Congress
across the support
we're striving to build a Ukraine that's
inclusive that's accessible so that
people with disabilities can reach their
full potential which is in the interests
of all ukrainians
my announcement today also comes on top
of the more than 2.1 billion dollars in
humanitarian assistance that we provided
to Ukraine and to the region to respond
to Russia's war of regression including
life-saving aid for those affected by
the destruction of the kokova dam
within hours of its breach we mobilize
support for evacuations for emergency
deliveries of food of safe drinking
water or fuel of Medical Aid
in the week since we continue to work
with Ukraine in assisting the thousands
of people who've been displaced the
hundreds of thousands
whose water supply has been contaminated
and these are just the immediate
consequences of the catastrophe that
will probably wreak environmental and
economic Devastation for many months and
indeed many years to come
meanwhile the United Nations has
publicly called out Moscow for blocking
the U.N from delivering Aid to civilians
in the flooded areas that Russia
illegally occupies
adding to Russia's long track record of
denying humanitarian access which is a
requirement under International
humanitarian law
in addition to our Economic Development
humanitarian assistance the United
States will continue to invest in
Ukraine's long-term efforts to
strengthen good governance transparency
accountability
justice sector and anti-corruption
institutions strengthen its civil
society and its Free Press
these institutions and organizations
Empower ukrainians to hold their
government accountable
to check the power of vested interests
and they're crucial to ensuring that the
unprecedented resources that all of us
are providing are managed responsibly
the Ukrainian government has made
meaningful strides in bolstering these
institutions even as a fight for
survival
and Kiev has taken tangible and
difficult steps
to align its standards and practices
with the European Union particularly
since the EU granted Ukraine candidate
status a year ago
earlier this month Ukraine passed
reforms to align its energy Market
regulations with the European Union
strengthening measures to combat Market
manipulation and insider trading and we
look forward to the route of taking up
anti-monopoly legislation very soon
adopting these and other critical
reforms to increase Ukraine's
transparency competitiveness to bolster
the rule of law
will help attract more private
investment
and that is essential and you heard it
from my colleagues
governments are doing a lot
International financial institutions are
doing a lot
both of us have a usually important role
to play in Ukraine's recovery but it is
not enough only the private sector
can mobilize the level of investment
necessary to meet the country's massive
needs
the diverse participation of the private
sector here today in this conference
shows the growth opportunity that Global
firms and investors see in the future of
Ukraine in the future of its people
but make no mistake
all of these reforms and Recovery
efforts
depend on Ukraine having the capacity to
deter and defend against future attacks
by Russia
that's why even as we invest in
Ukraine's immediate and long-term
recovery
we also have to build a Ukrainian
military that is strong enough
to protect Ukraine's sovereignty its
territorial integrity and its
independence
not just to defend Ukraine's land
but to defend all that ukrainians are
building and will build on that land
it's also why the United States is
committed to working to build support
for a just and Lasting peace in Ukraine
the core elements of which I outlined a
couple of weeks ago in Helsinki
those include a piece that upholds the
United Nations Charter and its
fundamental principles sovereignty
territorial Integrity Independence that
addresses both accountability and
Reconciliation
that ensures Ukraine's full
participation and ascent
and that supports Ukraine's
reconstruction and Recovery
as we rally around Ukraine's recovery
we must not lose sight of why that is
necessary in the first place
indeed
even as we come together here in London
committed to supporting Ukraine's build
up Russia continues to try to burn it
down
so
let's be clear
Russia is causing Ukraine's destruction
and Russia will eventually bear the cost
of Ukraine's reconstruction
until that time until that time we will
continue to stand with the people of
Ukraine as they make the greatest
sacrifices to defend to rebuild
to reimagine their country
and in doing so
we will reaffirm the principle at the
heart of the international order
that people in every nation can write
their own future
free from aggression free from coercion
free from intimidation
that is a recovery well worth our robust
and enduring support thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen Allah chorus the
president of Estonia thank you
[Applause]
excellences ministers
ladies and gentlemen dear friends
our response to Russian aggressive
destruction will be creation
we will help to rebuild and create a new
Innovative sustainable and digital
Ukraine
will not wait until the war is over
in fact we already started
I am pleased to note that on the 2nd of
June the first Estonian reconstruction
project was completed
a kindergarten in recipient of which
this perfect example of public private
partnership brought happiness to many
kids and their parents
but also to us it is gratifying feeling
to do the Good Deeds
as we continue with other projects let
me show that reconstruction is not only
needed but as we saw in overage it is
already possible
I urge everyone to start now with smart
efforts and not restore the old but
build future-proof Ukraine that can
Inspire us all
Estonia has worked with Ukraine for
years to support public sector reforms
and help increase its resilience
we redoubled our efforts in 2014 when
Russian regression started
and again before the start of a
large-scale war in 2022
Estonian private sector has been
instrumental in our cooperation peat
development tembita the backbone of the
digital government of Ukraine that has
helped the country continue offering
Public Services even during the war
the latest example of the kindergarten
it was realized by the Estonian at
wooden house custom and its member
hermit together with European Ukrainian
subsidiary of the main contractor
nordicon
Estonian construction companies have a
high motivation to offer European
construction standards and reliable
partnership in the next stage of a
deconstruction of Ukraine
I recently returned from a visit to
Ukraine with a business delegation and
witnessed a great work
great interest to work with and invest
in Ukraine
estonians reacted fast to all critical
needs of their Ukrainian people
it includes includes cash-based support
generators passes and Equipment of
humanitarian demining
the recent example is sending necessary
equipment rubber boots water pumps Etc
the region of of the explosion of kahov
kadam and other disastrous exercise
caused by Russian innovation
Ukraine has the potential to become
become one of the most successful
economies in Europe
I saw this in my recent visit to Ukraine
while meeting with students scientists
officials from anti-corruption agency
praised enormous enthusiasm and
willingness to bring on the long-waited
chains
it is important to provide a
comprehensive policy framework as well
as funding support for skilled and
educated ukrainians which will allow
them to return to Ukraine one day
for this investment in The annotation to
recovery are needed
it will also support Ukraine on its way
to joining EU and NATO
membership of these organizations is
essential to achieve our common goal of
creating a peaceful Europe and
protecting the sustainability of our
investments
the scale of a challenge at hand is
almost unimaginable
we need a common approach to make the
best use of our resources
this can be done by involving all
Partners big and small public and
private
and leveraging the long-term experience
from religion
ladies and gentlemen
our companies continue to operate in
Ukraine
some never stopped reflection and kept
all Personnel employed
like PRT Group which is currently
investing into a new strategic project
to ensure the stability of supply of
vital gases in Ukraine
I would also like to mention mortal
Estonian company Port Ukrainian I.T
company Scalia just a few months after
the war started and employs today
350 Ukrainian employees in its offices
in Kiev and
according to Nato the decision was made
in Ukraine's favor because of a
qualified Workforce and higher level of
digitalization
Ukrainian I.T sector have shown great
growth even during the war
in a defense industry the third system
and Milan robotics have done successful
cooperation and are supplying high-level
drones and unmanned crowned Vehicles
configured to transport the wounded and
equipment
We Stand ready share our
experience and help in any way we can
and we remain committed to our proposal
to organize Ukraine for construction
conference
thank you very much Slava okay
thank you Mr President now can I ask
christianis Karens the Prime Minister of
Latvia to the stage thank you
[Applause]
excellencies ladies gentlemen friends
I'll just try to say a few words so many
good speeches I can only agree with
everything
um
flashback to the uh
fall and winter of 21 22. the Latvian
government starts getting briefings from
the U.S government
every morning I'm reading about new
troop movements every week in the
government meeting now we're meeting in
the special
room that is good for such meetings and
we're trying to understand what exactly
is going on what could we expect now
Latvia has a history with Russia where
we never had any illusions that things
are going very well to our East and we
had every indication that things are
actually going
in an absolutely bad Direction so we
took a decision
at the late fall early in November
December that we wanted to send weapons
to Ukraine it doesn't look good it looks
like a war really could erupt we have
had now a stinger missiles in our
Arsenal well you don't just send these
things around you you coordinate with
U.S government it took a little while
our Stingers arrived in Ukraine just one
day before The full-scale Invasion and
thankfully they were part of the
solution of keeping the Russians from
taking the airport which is part of
their initial plan
um
since that time
our government has spent over 1.3
percent of our GDP
on all kinds of Aid to Ukraine over one
percent is military alone so our
stingler missiles all of our Stinger
missiles are now in Ukraine we had a
fleet of helicopters all of those
helicopters the last ones are still
being repainted we we send them so that
they're usable and look good as well uh
are going to Ukraine we are training
Ukrainian soldiers to the order of about
three thousand uh this year uh uh
ammunition drones
etc etc is continually going and will
continue to go in this way on top of
that humanitarian Aid on top of that
financial aid and on top of all of this
our civil society has been going
head-to-head with the government who can
donate more faster and more efficiently
so after the kahovka dam was exploded
within one week we took three different
government decisions on different Aid
packages coordinated with ukrainians but
at the same time our civil society
spontaneous it's it's very well
organized in Latvia organizing all kinds
of shipments of generators boats
everything that is needed in in flood
devastated areas to get them there and
they're already on the ground and
working today
so as a nation
we understand the ukrainians
because
what are they fighting for they're
fighting for
many things but you could boil it down
to three values
Freedom has been mentioned democracy has
been mentioned in the rule of law now
all of us we talk about these things all
the time we're all Freedom Fighters
but friends the ukrainians are Freedom
Fighters we are now Freedom supporters
thank you
and what we need to do is to persevere
and my message to you is simple a small
country like Latvia if we can spend 1.3
percent of our GDP
so can you we're not the wealthiest of
Nations
but
it can it can be done and as a
politician I can say
um actually uh it it it's good for
Politics as well so the more you you
give Aid the higher your ratings go I
can assure that to everyone around the
room
now
we're speaking about reconstruction
today Latvia is committed to the Chinese
region this is also uh in in working
together with the Ukrainian government a
very specific needs very specific
projects that we're working on and what
we're also seeing in Latvia
interestingly that uh trade business
trade between Latvia and Ukraine is up
over 60 percent this year in the middle
of a war UH 60 increase and why is that
it's because on top of all of the eight
more and more companies are realizing
they have an important role to play Not
only in donating but in helping to
create so also today the companies from
the energy sector from the language
technology sector from other sectors in
in Latvia present here today
looking for these opportunities and if
we can mobilize not only public funds
but the private funds
that is one incredible opportunity for
for everyone for the ukrainians but for
all of Europe now and what is the the
the sort of the end game the outcome how
will it all end uh well there are a
number of steps so first and basic
Ukraine will win the war and Ukrainian
territory will be liberated of the
Russian aggressor everywhere that is
point one that needs our continued
especially Military Support
[Applause]
we have to help Ukraine in the
integration process Ursula uh I don't
see it right now uh ursulfunded Alliance
said very correctly Ukraine's place will
be in the European Union no doubt about
that and we will become stronger because
of uh you're joining us but I think it's
also important to state that at the end
of the day if we want a long-standing
peace in Europe the only way to really
assure that is Ukraine's also full
integration into the NATO military
Alliance
another important aspect it has been
mentioned it needs to be stressed that
the perpetrator must pay the Russians
are destroying Ukraine we have Frozen
billions probably trillions of their
assets a way must be found to mobilize
these assets to help offset the cost of
the Reconstruction and finally the
Russian leadership must be held
accountable ultimately in a Tribunal for
all of the atrocities and the crimes
against humanity that they are
perpetrating even as we speak so united
we will stand we will stand with and
behind Ukraine and in the end we will
prevail Slava Ukraine
ladies and Gentlemen please can I invite
Antonio tayani foreign minister and
Deputy Prime Minister of Italy thank you
[Applause]
Mr Prime Minister
their colleagues
James thank you very much
for organizing in Austin
this very important event
the Ukraine recovery conference
is first of all a political meeting
because today we are sending a very
clear political message to everybody
Festival to Russia we are united
Europeans Americans
many many countries many many
governments many many states many many
entrepreneurs public and private sector
United in defense of the international
law this is the clear and important
message
for today
we are in defense
of the rules not all in defense of the
independence of Ukraine because the
independence of Ukraine is freedom is
peace is Justice his international law
for this we are strong and engaged today
and of course
the it's impossible to achieve peace
without Justice we want peace
that peace without Justice is not peace
Justice is the freedom of Ukraine
and if you want to pay the way
for a better future
for your county Mr Prime Minister
if we want to pave the way for a full
membership of Ukraine in the European
Union
if you want to pay the way
for your food membership in the NATO in
the next few years
we need to work for the reconstruction
we need to work all together
my country my government
the Italian government is strongly
engaged in this strategy
we want to be protagonists for helping
you for in defense of the freedom
because your freedom is our freedom
as you know their prime minister
just a few weeks ago we were
with you with your government in Rome in
the presence more or less 1000 Italian
Ukrainian companies to discuss the
Reconstruction of your account
for Italy the bilateral reconstruction
conference in Rome was the start of the
process in which Italy together with the
European Union the International
Community is committed to providing
Ukraine
with the strong military
humanitarian financial and economic
assistance
Italy
will keep playing a center role with
this G7 presidency next year
and then by hosting this Ukraine
recovery conference in 2025
started building Ukraine
we don't have to wait for the end of the
conflict
as often
reminded by the president Celeste there
are many things that we can do
together
first of all the Russian attempt to
exploit the winter to bring the Civil
civilian population to its knees
we must work now to restore what has
been destroyed by the end of the summer
starting with the energy infrastructure
which eater is committed with public
funds and its National companies
secondary we can immediately remove the
Marines
as in the field and rebuild the bridges
roads houses and schools and hospitals
this is crucial for a better life of
ukrainians
Italy is committed to
bring the resource gap for early
recovery highlighted by the war Banks
assessment assessment last March
resources are mentioned by the announced
by the confidence of the Reconstruction
in Rome amounting to 200 Millions
Euro will be used in this direction in
particular to support energy security
and critical infractions infrastructures
our now is ready for you is ready for
Ukraine
Italy is an industrial County
four
thousand small and medium-sized
companies
this is the heart of our economy
our is very important the made in Italy
is very important and we want to export
to Ukraine our Medi Italy
it's important
to work
in the respect of the rules of the
multilateral development Banks
but this is crucial to do it for the
Reconstruction to be successful the
contribution of the pride investment
private investment is very important we
need your help
we need your involvement in this
political strategy
the freedom
the free market
is crucial for growth is crucial for
everybody
is crucial for our companies
Ukraine will be parts
of our internal Mark of the European
internal Market it will be present now
is also to be present in the future to
be friends as Europeans all together and
we want Ukraine full members as I said
of the European Union but also the
Western Balkans
countless candidate we want to work all
together
of course Ukraine is a country keeper
with the resources space and talent and
offers great Investments opportunity
this is the message we must convey to
the business world
in this Spirit they are prime minister
I have appointed the new special Envoy
the last ambassador to give
that will be the Italian focal point for
the Reconstruction process this is a
clear message we have strongly engaged
we want to work more we want to work
with our friends
you want
our our companies are ready to invest in
Ukraine
it is also essential that the refer path
undertaking by the county continuous
in the fusion the construction process
is indeed closely linked to the Assassin
process to the European Union as I said
Italy has immediately supported keep
European aspiration and will continue to
work in this direction when we will
decide to start the negotiation ladder
this year only Ukrainian technician the
European project can guarantees to our
continent a future of Peace stability
and prosperity and is therefore a
Strategic investment for this I said
this is a today
we are part of the political
confidence for me this is very very
important
they are friends
their their career friends
they are friends of G7 the European
friends the American friends
count on Italy
count on Italian government
prime minister we are close to you in
defense of Freedom democracy
peace
international law zlabo crane
absolutely
thank you Antonia and can I now invite
Angelina bear book German Federal
Minister for foreign affairs thank you
thank you foreign secretary thank you
James
Prime Ministers presidents excellencies
prime minister shimak ladies and
gentlemen
the only thing I wish for is to go back
to school
play volleyball
with my friends
and live a normal life
this is what a teenager 16 years old
said to me when I met her in khakif in
January
at a warming Center in the midst of a
city destroyed by Russian bombs
at -15 degrees
she told me how Counting
to 45
had become part of her daily life since
the start of the Russian war of
aggression
because it takes 45 seconds
for Russian missiles
to hit hark if after you hear the
syrians
45 seconds
if you're lucky
it's enough to get your little brother
or your grandmother to safety
at 45 seconds that is not enough
for a normal life
45 seconds is not enough to go to school
45 seconds is not enough to play
volleyball
I believe that today's conference is
about these teenagers in khakif
the boys and girls and their generation
it is about supporting Ukraine to build
a future in which all of ukrainians will
again live in Freedom security and peace
from the moment Russia began its
ruthless war of aggression on the 24th
of February last year
all of us in this room have stood
resolutely by the side of Ukraine by the
ukrainian's right to defend themselves
commitment does not stop here
for the German government like all the
other governments this commitment stands
for as long as it takes
we counter
we counter altogether Putin's
destructive war of aggression was a
rebuilding campaign
United in defense United in rebuilding
we continue to support Ukraine
financially politically with weapons
we want Ukraine to win this war to win
peace
that is why we have made clear that
Ukraine belongs also to the European
family
and the commissioner President also La
fundamining said this morning that the
European Commission on Ukraine's reform
effort shows that Ukraine is making
commendable progress despite the war
and Ukraine will eventually become a
member of the European Union
was our
past we are also working towards greater
political and practical cooperation
between Ukraine and NATO
and my colleague Minister for
development schultzer and I have come
today here to underline that the German
government is stepping up efforts for
Ukraine's recovery
this recovery starts with humanitarian
support
Germany will provide Ukraine with an
additional
381 million euro for humanitarian
assistance in 2023 for everything from
generators to food and tents for those
who have fled or lost their homes
recently
we will continue our demining work since
there can be no peace in places where
people live in constant fear
of their children stepping on a mine
while playing
this support comes on top to the total
recovery assistant by the foreign office
the ministry of development the ministry
of economy and many others in the German
government
because yes recovery is about money it
needs to be
since the beginning of Russia's War
Germany has provided 16.8 billion Euro
in support relating to Russia's
aggression against Ukraine including
military Ed and we applaud those
countries connected to the GDP have done
similar
but when we look at long-term
reconstruction money is not enough
we want to support Ukraine in building
back better as we called it last year's
recovery conference in Lugano Italy
this means that in rebuilding its power
sector we are helping Ukraine to invest
in renewable energy and Energy
Efficiency in a recovery that is green
and therefore longer lasting and
sustainable
and reconstruction is a collective
effort that will only succeed if public
and private sectors work together as you
James has said so many times
despite the war and its damage to
Hurricane's economy many German
companies continue to operate in Ukraine
in healthcare in energy in food in water
and they see reconstruction as others as
an opportunity of growth
I applaud them for this
they not only provide good services and
jobs
they provide trust in the future of
Ukraine
as German government we therefore
supporting them with national investment
guarantees because yes this is also
political
and recall on others to follow suit so
that companies do not shy away from
investing in Ukraine
finally I'm convinced that we need to
further link Ukraine's recovery and the
EU accession process
our goal is to help rebuild a Ukraine
that is fit for EU
we send ready to support Ukraine in its
reform efforts on the past two words
membership
that's why Ukraine's accession process
will have a special place
at next year's recovery conference to be
held in Germany to make recovery a truly
European endeavor
ladies and gentlemen colleagues and
Friends
we do not know
when Russia will stop its brutal war of
aggression it's in the hand of one man
who has started this war
but what we know
and what we promise
we will continue supporting Ukraine's
recovery and we will continue helping
Ukraine
to win this war to win peace
so that every teenage girl in Ukraine
can do what teenage girls are doing in
the rest of Europe every day
go to school without fear
play volleyball with your friends
without counting to 45
simply live a normal life in Peace and
Freedom
thank you
[Applause]
and now can I invite yoshimasa Hayashi
foreign minister of Japan
[Applause]
thank you James and prime minister's
ministers distinguished guests ladies
and gentlemen
I am Hayashi bushimasa Minister for
foreign affairs of Japan
I would like to express my respect for
efforts made by the governments of the
UK and acclaim and with those involved
in organizing this confluence
I particularly commend the UK's
readership
in organizing this confluence
first of all I would like to reiterate
our sympathy and solidarity with the
people of acclaim
especially foreign
and express my strong concern about its
enormous impact
Japan decided to provide 5 million US
dollars in emergency
humanitarian assistance to those
affected by the floods in such earlier
as food Water Sanitation and health
and in addition we will provide upper
Christmas tree 160 water purifiers about
530 generators
study construction machines and other
equipments through Japan International
cooperation agency jaika and an
international organization
we will also Implement emergency
humanitarium assistance through ngos
Japan the only country that has ever
suffered atomic bombings during wartime
has achieved a miraculous development
from the devastation after the war
we have also experienced a series of
serious natural disasters
including the great hanshin awaji
earthquake in 1995. and the Great East
Japan earthquake in 2011.
with tsunami
each time however
we have achieved remarkable recovery and
reconstruction
with the support of our friends
in the International Community
Japan therefore has experience and
knowledge publicably and deconstruction
gains through overcoming such
difficulties
during the visit to Japan for the G7
Hiroshima Summit president zielinski
stated that he dreams that city
destroyed by Lucia will be rebuilt into
a peaceful City like Hiroshima of today
Japan intends to make use of its
experience and knowledge it has
accumulated in the field of recovery and
reconstruction and the Big Lots
re-implement
uniquely Japanese form of reconstruction
assistance ink laws conduct with the
claimed people
the G7 Hiroshima Summit the leaders
confirmed the importance of the law of
the private sector in the recovery and
reconstruction of a claim which is one
of the main subject of this confluence
how's the G7 we issued a joined
statement and in which we welcomed The
Establishment Hope to support full
claims reconstruction and economy sure
trust fund in the multilateral
investment guarantee agency Mega as well
as the launch of the claim investment
platform read by Japan's jpeg
Japan contributed 23 million US dollars
to the sure trust fund of the meager
as for the Ukrainian investment platform
we welcome that signing ceremony for its
launch is taking place later today
and I'm and I'm convinced that based on
the outcomes of the G7 Hiroshima Summit
meaningful discussions will be made at
this conference and the leadership of
the UK on necessary measures to promote
the involvement of the private sector
including War Risk insurance with a bill
to stimulating the insurance market and
implementation of reforms in uclaim
in order to gain further involvement of
the private sector
in Japan has recently established the
Council on preparation for promotion of
a claims economic reconstruction with
the participation of all the relevant
ministers Ministries and agencies
furthermore
the Japan playing Confluence for
promotion of economic reconstruction
will be held at an appropriate timing
from the end of this year to the
beginning of next year
so that the Japanese public and private
sectors can strongly support the
recovery and reconstruction of a claim
Japan has so far announced over 7.6
billion dollars in support including
humanitarian assistance and
winterization assistance to vulnerable
people
in a medium and long term regardly and
reconstruction Noble claim Japan will
make use of its strengths and provide
assistance mainly in the areas of number
one mind action and deadly clearance
number two in livelihood reconstruction
including the development of basic
infrastructure such as electricity
number three the recovery of Agriculture
production and Industrial Development
and number four strengthening democracy
and governance
concrete initiatives are already
underway
for example with regard to mine action
in January this year Japan conducted
training for the Personnel of the state
emergency emergency service or Proclaim
to use mine detection equipment which
Japan is providing in cooperation with
Cambodia where Japan has wrong supported
mine action
Japan also organized seminars on
awareness raising activities for local
communities regarding mind lists we will
continue to provide minor related
assistance
in order to give proclaimed people hope
for a bright future
it is essential not only that the
International Community
shows the strong commitment to the
likable and reconstruction of a claim
but also that efforts to restore peace
to the country should be made
at the G7 Hiroshima Summit
the leaders we are found that the G7 is
more united than ever
strong support for claim in every aspect
and continuing to impose strict
sanctions against Russia
it was also confirmed with invited
countries outside of G7
that any unilateral attempt to change
the status quo by force is unacceptable
anywhere in the world and upholding the
free and open International order based
on the little ball is really essential
we will continue to walk closely in
cooperation with the International
Community to achieve adjust and Lasting
peace in the claim as soon as possible
I wish that this recovery Confluence
will be held successfully and that its
outcomes will be milestones in the
future the construction of a claim
Japan always stuns with Ukraine thank
you very much
[Applause]
thank you please now can I invite
Catherine Colona foreign minister of the
Republic of France
[Applause]
thank you foreign secretary dear James
on has a governance prime minister of
Canada and it's good to see you here
ministers ladies and gentlemen
excellencies dear friends I see a few in
the room
I want to start by thanking the
government of the United Kingdom for
hosting us today
our gathering today is a symbol of our
shared conviction that ukran will defeat
the Russian aggression
there will be a time when the war ends
and the kind will be standing as a
strong Sovereign United
and Democratic country resolutely
encoded the euro-atlantic family and in
Europe
and when I say in Europe I mean in the
European Union
this time this time hasn't come yet we
know that war is Raging
Russia's authorities are still denying a
credit's right to exist as a sovereign
country
Russia's soldiers are still illegally
occupying parts of a client's territory
Russia's missiles are still targeting
the Ukrainian population and critical
civilian infrastructures which is by
international law a war crime
our main focus therefore remains on
emergency driven support
it is the case for Military Support
and we've been making our best efforts
all of us to provide a kind with the
equipments it needs and in time in order
to support an ongoing counter-offensive
France delivered what it said it would
deliver
and it will keep doing it
it is also the case with the
humanitarian and civilian support we
provide
to respond to disasters Girls by
Russia's aggression such as the
destruction of the kafkovka dam
to increase the kinds of resilience or
to preserve the safety of a Korean
civilian nuclear power plants
is the logic that drove the
International Conference we organized in
Paris on December 30th last year and I'd
like to thank all those who did
participate
but focusing on the emergency imposed by
the outgoing War should not stop us from
thinking long term for at least two
reasons
one you kind of engage on a long-term
transformation effort through its EU
accession process
we need to use the Reconstruction phase
to give a crane a head start in this
process
two a commitment to support a class
reconstruction is also a signal we sent
to Putin
a signal the test will be here as long
as it takes and that they will not be
able to write us out
a signal that should convince Russia it
is in a deadlock and as to end its
aggression now
in order to
in order to achieve this goal
France is preparing a multi-year
civilian assistant package to Ukraine
that will include both humanitarian
stabilization economic and financial
support
I am pleased to add that it will mostly
be comprised in Grants
so as to avoid increasing the pressure
on a Current public finances
in the meantime
I'm happy to inform that my ministry
will be providing an additional 40
million euros in donations foreign
twenty three
disciple will be used primarily for
emergency reconstructions of critical
infrastructure
health equipment and if needed energy
resilience in a distribution of the next
winter
we will also take concrete steps to
encourage our private sector to
contribute to this effort it is much
needed
to that end I'm announcing today the
establishment of an insurance mechanism
to cover investments in Ukraine against
well-related risks via the French public
Investment Bank
this is totally consistent with the
military Insurance mechanism proposed by
the UK and Ukraine which we support
last but not least we fully support
courageous reforms president zeldinski
has pledged to undertake in order to
Foster the rule of law and to improve
the business climate in the country
these efforts will be key to attract
private investment without which
reconstruction will not be possible
thanks to our joints efforts ucan will
build back and build back better
up until then our support will not fade
thank you
[Applause]
and please now can I invite as a big
narrow foreign minister of Poland
[Applause]
thank you thank you James
prime minister's excellencies ladies and
gentlemen
friends
for the last couple of weeks the world
has been closely following the actions
of Ukraine Armed Forces systematically
liberating the Homeland
it damaged discovered in recaptured
territories is staggering
it is staggering but it's barbaric
nature
and it's overwhelming
by scale
recent genius Act of blowing up of a dam
in Nova
kahoffkat rustically adds to the
complicity
our long-term efforts towards
reconstruction
the process of reconstruction itself
will mean substant substantive
involvement of Republic as well as
private sector and business to a large
extent
our task
as the governments is to prepare the
appropriate institutional and legal
flame framework political support on the
sport and Financial Resources the
mobilization of Financial Resources will
be a major
long-term challenge
I would like to again stronger reiterate
assets should serve as key source
in this respect
it is clear that Moscow should be kept
legally accountable for the aggression
but it should also pay for the enormous
Damage Done
to Ukraine
[Applause]
the success of reconstruction of Ukraine
is in the best interest of Europe and
the whole International Community
it is in our interest that Ukraine
becomes a robust in the diverse market
economy playing by the rules with the
administration capable to absorb the
assistance
this is why
Ukraine should become a member of the
European Union Union as soon as possible
as it has been said
today in Brussels the European
commission is presenting the informal
update on the progress made by Kiev
since it was given a candidate status
we all know how effective Ukraine has
been in meeting with seven criteria
despite the ongoing War continuous
missiles attacks and the flood caused by
the destruction of them
Ukraine will be ready to start accession
negotiations soon
he visits the case
the EU should also be ready by the end
of this year
after the regular Autumn enlargements
report
the concept of a merit-based process
must work both ways
ladies and gentlemen
Poland has already proven its
credibility by providing humanitarians
and Military aids to Ukraine during the
war
we are ready to play a trust Warfare and
reliable partner also for for its
possible reconstruction we are equipped
to play with special role as a transport
Logistics and international hub
our key assets are
the geographical proximity the longest
EU border
with
Ukraine well-developed infrastructure of
border crossings
long-standing experience and the
competitive business cooperation offer
of Polish entrepreneurs on the Ukraine
Market
let me mention a few Elements which we
have already done
preparing for this enormous challenge
more than 2 000 polish companies
have approached the Polish threat and
investment agency
expressing interest in cooperation with
Ukrainian Partners in the recovery
process
we are reassuming the operation of a
police trade and investment agency
office in Kiev
in the end of June
to give a clear signal to polish and
international companies that the Ukraine
Market already provides great
opportunities
credibank owned by the pko BP
already providing affordable credit for
Ukraine
small and medium-sized Enterprises
the government has prepared the law
enabling the extension of insurance
coverage
for the transport of goods to and from
Ukraine as well as investment activities
for the last year the published official
export credit agency was the only one
ensuring trade receivables
on this basis
Poland will create a dedicated program
of rebuilding Ukraine
betrayed the insurance to Ukraine will
be provided also to foreign companies
operating in Poland
or willing to invest
I'm convinced that polish companies
taking into account the meaningful
relationships they have already
established with Ukrainian partners
are ready to develop
their father together with International
partners
thank you
[Applause]
and now can I invite harjit sajan
Minister for International Development
of Canada
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
and when I first take the opportunity to
thank the United Kingdom in Ukraine for
hosting us today
I also want to acknowledge the bravery
and the sacrifice of the Ukrainian
soldiers who are fighting on the front
lines
now it is not a secret that Canada's
ties with Ukraine run extremely deep
Canada is home to 1.4 million Ukrainian
Canadians
and they have made a significant mark on
our national identity and values
with Ukrainian Canadian Senator Paul
music who first brought forward the
vision of multiculturalism in Canada
with a pivotal Senate speech
another Ukrainian Canadian Lawrence
Decor helped write the section of our
Charter of Rights and Freedoms that
entrench multiculturalism in Canada's
Constitution
these Ukrainian Canadians saw in Canada
that recognized its deep connections to
The Wider world as an integral part of
Who We Are
and in the spirit of an interconnected
world I join you in this Resolute to
show of our International solidarity
with Ukraine
and just 10 days ago our prime minister
Justin Trudeau was on the ground in
Keith and while there we reinforced
Canada's enduring commitment to Ukraine
and announce new support measures
including increased military assistance
and support for mental health
Canada has committed over 8.8 billion
dollars in financial military
humanitarian development immigration
assistance for Ukraine and this includes
over five billion dollars in direct
financial assistance
with over 4.3 billion flowing through
the international monetary funds new
administered account for Ukraine which
was championed by Canada
this also includes a 500 million dollar
stemming from the proceeds of Canada's
Ukraine sovereignty Bond the first of
its kind globally
our commitments to Ukraine are
especially important in the face of the
evolving crisis elected destruction of
the uh the most the most recent Dam
Canada's allocating 10 million dollars
for humanitarian Partners to support the
people impacted by the floods
and I've visited Ukraine many times in
my former capacity as minister of
defense
and just a few months back I had the
opportunity to visit in my current
capacity and that trip allowed me to
personally witness what the world has
since has been seeing at a distance over
the last 16 months
what I witnessed was absolute resilience
and As We Gather here the people of
Ukraine continue to show the world just
how strong and resilient they are in the
face of unjustifiable and unwarranted
Russian aggression so today We Gather to
support not only Ukraine's immediate
needs
but its long-term recovery
reconstruction and economic future
a future that is safer and Greener more
open and more resilient
to upset the status on that path one
month ago at the G7 Summit Canada made a
landmark commitment to the European bank
for reconstruction and development
Ken announced 283 million for the high
impact partnership on climate action to
help countries build clean and climate
resilient economies
and today I'm announcing an additional
20 million dollars to the Ukraine Grant
as part of this initiative
the Ukraine Grant will support climate
adaptation mitigation and resilience
projects with a focus on technical
assistance
gender equality equality will also be
factored into this work something that
is central for Canada with our feminist
International assistance policy
Canada's also been a leader in Champion
creative Innovative Financial tools for
Ukraine and we will continue to look for
ways to leverage Innovative financial
instruments to provide the risking and
concessional support to Ukraine and
Canadian investors
Ukraine also continues its work to
combat corruption
and make progress on these reforms and
these efforts are more important than
ever
for your European union and OCD
accession and also to encourage more
private sector investment
and during my last uh most recent trip
during this trip I'll be meeting with
Canadian Business Leaders who are
looking to support Ukraine's recovery
and reconstruction through trade and
investment and in April Canada and
Ukraine concluded negotiates to
modernize our bilateral Free Trade
Agreement
this will provide a strong legal
framework for Canada's firms seeking to
participate in Ukraine's reconstruction
efforts I'd like to Express Canada
supports for the launch of the G7 plus
and the government of Ukraine's clean
energy partnership for Ukraine
as well as the launch of the Ukraine
business compact
Kendall also supports a framework on war
Risk insurance to support private sector
input into the Reconstruction activities
and Kendall firmly believes in the
importance of bringing our diplomatic
trade and development work together and
we need a truly United effort on this
front because as prime minister Justin
Trudeau said in Keith
Ukraine's fight for the future stretches
far beyond its borders Ukraine's fight
for the food Ukraine fights for the
future of all of us and for the values
that all of us hold so dear Canada is
honored to stand shoulder to shoulder uh
with you as we stand up for Ukraine
thank you Ukraine
uh ladies and gentlemen can I invite you
once again to thank in the traditional
way our panelists as they retake their
seats
um and uh in preparation for our final
keynote speech of this session but
ladies and gentlemen thank you so very
very much
ladies and gentlemen uh this session
underlines our Collective
determination to support Ukraine not
only in its self-defense but its
subsequent rebuild reform and Recovery
it gives me great pleasure to now
introduce to the stage the final speaker
of this session the keynote speaker of
this morning
the prime minister of Ukraine Dennis
schmeehan thank you
thank you so much your dreams
your president's Prime Ministers
secretaries ministers
dear heads of international
organizations their representatives of
international business your friends
Partners colleagues allies ladies and
gentlemen
today Ukraine is going to have the most
difficult through the most difficult
times in the history of our independence
it is a crucial time not only for our
country but also for Europe for the
Civilized world for democracy and
freedom
the outcome of the war in Ukraine will
determine the geopolitical landscape of
Europe for many decades come
16 months into war
no one doubts that Russia has not
achieved its goals Ukraine was stood
thanks to the heroism of the Ukrainian
Army thanks to The Bravery of Ukrainian
people
thanks to their leadership
thanks to the unity thanks to the
pro-ukrainian Coalition and your help
12 months ago Ukraine was granted the EU
candidate status we have an ambitious
goal to quickly become a member of the
European Union
we are already well ahead of schedule of
this path
we are Transforming Our Country
we are rapidly adopting European
policies and practices integrating into
European markets and straightening our
institutions European integration is a
compass for all reforms and changes
including the implementation of
Ukraine's recovery projects
I would like to express my gratitude to
the European Union for its consistent
military political financial and
humanitarian support in particular I
want to thank the European commission
and personally Madam president Ursula
thunderline for the initiative of new
Ukraine facility which will provide
medium and long-term support for our
economy and Recovery
the new Ukraine facility will also
support our efforts to rebuild and
modernize the country while implementing
key reforms on eaw accession track
over the past months we have laid the
basis for winning this war we believe
that we are going to win this war and we
will win the peace that fellows
I say we many times because this is our
common achievements our common work our
common tasks
we need to accomplish long-term
stability security and prosperity for
Ukraine and for the region
we have already begun our long and
difficult Journey on the journey on
rebuilding Ukraine a year ago in Lugano
we held the first major conference on
Ukraine's recovery
at that conference our discussions
primarily were around plans road maps
challenges and Prospects
a year later here in London our
discourse extend beyond beyond plants
encompassing notable achievements as
well we are now addressing the 10 key
aspects of Ukraine's recovery which
provide us with a competition of where
we are where we are going and what else
we need to do to win this piece the
first aspect of Ukraine's recovery
damage assessment we have said that the
first thing we need to start with
is an independent professional and
transparent assessment of damage and
reconstruction needs
together with the World Bank and the
European commission and the UN we have
created such a tool we have carried out
rapid damage and needs assessment this
document provides a comprehensive
overview of the impact of the war in 20
different sectors
as of 21st February this year
reconstruction needs have already
reached 411 billion dollars this is an
unprecedented figure unfortunately it
does not yet Encompass many losses
including the damages inflicted by the
horrific terrorist attack carried by
Russian forces at the kahovka
hydroelectric power station
we are grateful to the World Bank for
effectively assisting us and agreeing to
promptly conduct an assessment of the
damages resulting from this Dreadful
terrorist Act
we appreciate World bank's support in
evaluating all the losses and firmly
believe in the necessity of continuing
this work
therefore the program of large-scale
recovery and transformation of Ukraine
will also be unprecedented it will be
the largest reconstruction project in
Europe since their second World War
the second aspect of Ukraine's recovery
is stages of recovery the first stage is
rapid recovery which we started last
year and are now actively implementing
we are talking about projects that are
really necessary for the survival of the
country and the people in the face of
war the World Bank estimates that we
need 14.1 billion dollars for such
priority recovery projects this year
the second stage will be a long-term
reconstruction which will take many
years and we are now starting to lay
down a plan for its implementation
the third aspect of Ukraine's recovery
priorities for rapid recovery last year
we also talked about
the importance of setting the right
priorities for recovery for this year
our government has identified five key
priorities
these are energy humanitarian demining
housing critical and social
infrastructure and supporting the
economy
as I have already said we need 14.1
billion dollars for for the priority
tasks in these areas we have projects in
all these areas Ukrainian ministers will
present them in detail with calculations
responsible agencies and timelines
we expect that at this conference in
London we will finally be able to
mobilize the full amount needed for this
project this is a priority and a very
practical stories that we have to make
together
the first aspect of Ukraine recovery is
recovery architecture the implementation
of all these projects requires a special
recovery architecture and regular
platforms for cooperation last year we
created the position of Deputy Prime
Minister for restoration of Ukraine we
have also established the state agency
for restoration
the dedicated fund for overcoming the
consequences of aggression and the
in the position of Deputy ministers for
Recovery in the relevant departments we
are actively engaging Regional
authorities which is an important
element of the decentralization reform
alongside the internal recovery
architecture
we have established a new mechanism for
a regular interaction with our
International Partners this is the
multi-agency and donor coordination
platform for Ukraine
from now the Deputy Prime Minister for
restoration will be the representative
of Ukraine in this platform
the fifth aspect of Ukraine's recovery
is transparency
speaking about the recovery architecture
we have mentioned many times the words
transparency and accountability
we are making sure that these are not
just words Ukrainian reconstruction
should become synonymous with
transparency
last month we presented the digital
registration ecosystem for accountable
management or dream as we call it
the ecosystem will allow to control
every stage of any recovery project in a
very short period of time more than 5
000 sites for restoration have already
been entered into the system
there are six aspects for Ukraine's
recovery is parametric approach and
build back better principle
at the lugana conference we say that we
wanted to carry out recovery using two
approaches the parametric approach and
the regional approach the parametric
approach is the principle when the
government sets a general framework the
broad policies and the general
requirements
what does this mean in practice for
example we have set new requirements at
the legislative level for the
construction of residential buildings in
particular that they must now have a
bomb shelter
they have also developed requirements
for schools and hospitals and are
setting up community
safety centers
Energy Efficiency green technologies
security all these should be a mandatory
part of the new infrastructure in the
reconstruction
the seventh aspect of Ukraine recovery
is regional approach
the regional approach is when our
International partner countries take
patronage of regions and communities in
Ukraine and help Implement recovery
projects here
30 countries have signed a declaration
supporting the initiative to provide
provide coordinating assistance to
rebuild Ukrainian communities and
regions during last year more than 300
territorial communities in Ukraine have
signed
1500 partnership agreements nearly 60
countries are helping our city-stown
towns and villages to recover currently
more than 200 projects are being
implemented or have been implemented
jointly with partner countries or
International organizations
the eighth aspect of Ukraine's recovery
is sources of financing the recovery one
of the key questions we are constantly
facing is who will pay the hundreds of
billions for the recovery
first and foremost Russia must
pay for what it has destroyed
[Applause]
we are preparing a fair mechanism that
will allow us to confiscate up to 500
billion dollars of Russian assets Frozen
in the West
in May a historic decision was taken at
the meeting of the Council of Europe to
establish a register of damage caused by
Russia's aggression against Ukraine
this is the first component of the
international compensation mechanism the
second source of funding for
reconstruction is the Ukrainian budget
including funds from confiscated Russian
Assets in Ukraine
the Ukrainian budget for 2023 has
already earmarked 3.3 billion dollars
and we have already started
reconstruction with this funds the third
source is the assistance from our
International Partners including
International Financial organizations
we are grateful to all of you
our partners have already pledged 4.3
billion dollars out of the total 14.1
billion needed for the rapid recovery
for the next 12 months but we still need
another 6.55 billion dollars we have set
an ambitious goal of securing pledges
for this amount as a result of this
conference
the ninth aspect of Ukraine's recovery
is involvement of the private sector
no large-scale effective and rapid
recovery is possible without the
involvement of private capital and
private investment we believe that it is
business and entrepreneurs who can make
our recovery truly affect you we are
already offering projects and investment
opportunities to International Capital
together with the World Bank the U.S
International Development Financial
Corporation and other partners we are
working on an effective War Risk
insurance model for investment in
Ukraine we have identified identified
five key segments that will
from the basis for the recovery and
transformation of our economy the first
sector is energy
there is a huge potential in the
electricity sector gas production and
storage and also hydrogen energy
president of Ukraine emphasized today in
his in his speech on this sector
especially the second sector is a multi
is a military industrial complex many
Ukrainian weapons and developments are
proving their effectiveness on their
Battlefield right now European and
Global defense companies are
increasingly considering options for
building new production facilities in
Ukraine after the war we expect a great
boost in the development of this sector
in Ukraine the third sector is
agriculture Ukraine is already world
leader in the production of many crops
with government incentives and private
foreign investments we believe that
post-war grows in this sector could be
in double digits
the fourth sector is is infrastructure
the recorded losses of this sector now
extend exceed over 100 billion dollars
commercial destruction so for many years
it will be the market that is worse than
of billions of euros we will actively
offer public private partnership and
Concession projects
the fifth sector is I.T we have
ambitious to become a digital Hub in
Europe we offer it companies some of the
most favorable tax and Regulatory
conditions in the world in general we
are telling the private sector that
those who invest in Ukraine today will
have extraordinary opportunities and
Prospects in coming years
the tense aspect of Ukraine recovery
Ukraine is changing recovery of Ukraine
is not just about rebuilding a power
plant a road a house or a hospital
recovery of Ukraine is also about the
transformation of our country a new
quality of Institutions and a new living
space a new European Ukraine
the plants changes and reforms are
clearly in line with our aspirations to
become a member of EU we understand that
Ukraine must change and Ukraine is
transforming right now
for this year our government has
identified 10 priority reforms and
transformation projects European
integration security and defense new
veterans policy human capital
development in the face of extraordinary
challenges new economic model logistic
development and of course rapid recovery
in addition we have fully established
the anti-corruption anti-corruptional
infrastructure the National
anti-corruptional Bureau the specialized
anti-corruption prosecutor's office the
high anti-corruption court the national
Agency on corruption prevention these
are important institutions that allow us
to ensure the principle of inevitability
in punishment
of punishment and the rule of law
at the same time our government is
carrying out a major digitalization
reform a large-scale regulation for
doing business the corporatization and
the privatization of state-owned
Enterprises Enterprises these are the
necessary changes that will allow us
to prevent corruption dear friends dear
Partners Ukraine Ukraine is changing and
Ukraine is winning
our Victory will be the beginning of a
renew it and stronger Europe we are
united in defense and we will be United
in recovery we are grateful to every
everyone who is helping us fight for our
freedom and Independence today
I would also like to express my
gratitude to the government of the
United Kingdom personally to prime
minister Rishi sunak and Secretary of
State James cleverley
for co-organizing this conference this
perfect conference such events enable us
to synchronize our efforts and work
together towards the Victory and
recovery of Ukraine thank you for your
attention thank you for your tremendous
support thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you everyone thanks for that
terrific morning we've heard courage and
we've heard commitment and we're now
going to take a break we're going to be
back here first hard start at 11 40 so
that we can run a session on those
immediate needs that we've been
discussing so if you could all be seated
again at 11 40 thank you very much
all right
[Music]
I remember that day
I remember each day
I remember fear
and hatred
I remember them
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
the session is
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
until
Origins
please thank you seats the session is
about to begin
I've been over there
just checking if you guys will happen
Cassie
especially
appointments this is basically yeah
yeah
they say that the players have a lot of
nice
good morning
ministers your excellencies
distinguished guests decision makers if
we could have you seated now for the
next session we're going to run on quite
a tight schedule so we do need to get
started
um no
Everyone likes up here
yes
thank you everyone we're ready to start
now the next session uh talking about
the immediate needs for the Ukraine
recovery so I'm delighted to welcome on
stage as our keynote speaker for this
the Deputy Prime Minister for
restoration of Ukraine oleksander
kubrikov
[Applause]
good afternoon colleagues good afternoon
friends first of all I would like to say
thank you to UK site for organizing this
great event I hope that we will all see
like as soon as possible practical
results of our conference if I may just
start from presentation
I have a few slides
yeah
like our scope since the beginning of
this war it's
several key directions first of all it
was at the beginning of the war Civil
Logistics evacuation of our people it's
more than four million people were
created from harki from Kiev from as the
largest city of Ukraine
second it's military logistics it's key
starting from the third day of the war
one of one of the most probably the most
important Direction in our daily work
grain from Ukraine and Black Sea grain
initiative plus solidarity lands all
those activities are critical because
before the war and especially during the
war agricultural sector is number one
expert industry for Ukraine and as far
as you know
the service to our soldiers who are
paying from our taxes so the uh
this industry and to maintain in our
agricultural industry it's like one of
the first and the most important tasks
critical restoration
we will provide more details a little
bit later but again last year we
realized several projects and it was
mostly temporary solutions after the
occupation of territories to be
constructed temporary bypasses temporary
Bridges but all those measures sale
allow us to provide at least basic
services to those the occupied regions
uh
uh I'm sorry it's not working
yep at the same time uh we can plan uh a
lot of things we can plan the
restoration process we can we will
discuss a little bit later about how we
are planning prioritization uh but we
are facing this challenges which we
cannot predict first of all it was
attacks on civilian infrastructure last
year
we're faced with
blackouts real blackouts during winter
period and it was like again everybody
expecting something that it will happen
but uh like you cannot believe that
Russian they can do this but they're
doing this and then it was
dispersion and you see that like the the
next challenge will be to provide water
supply for one million people in nepro
region and this like at this moment
probably one of the key problems they
are not talking about
agricultural Theater which in Herson
region the consultant part of Ukraine
really
historically use water from water
reserves uh and trade blockade uh each
time we are inventing something uh like
again since again to our partners black
sea green initiative was established
with help of United Nations with the
help of uh turkey and our allies the
seven countries solidarity lines it was
established with in cooperation with EU
all those measures there as they allow
us to increase experts through
alternative channels but again without
black seed corridors for us it will be
it will be huge challenge to export new
Harvest to our traditional markets and
to to to provide more confidence for our
partners and to decrease risk of Global
Food security
again some figures just to provide you
uh what what is happening uh what we're
trying to cover what's already covered
if we're talking about uh like I'm not
on purpose we are not showing like
figures money because again they keep
they keep I think element for us it's
it's it's Figures it's a number of those
measures I will I would focus on housing
and last year we did minor Repairs by
ourselves with local authorities with
financial we provided financing from
central government and we did everything
as it was possible to do with minimum
financing but you see a apartment
building buildings I mean the number is
huge destroyed it's about 18 000 from
the beginning of the war significant
part of of those
buildings they are not located on
territories which we are not now
temporary and not on the Ukrainian
control but still numbers huge private
houses and what is good we recently
launched a recovery program again we are
using very transparent mechanism with
supplications which each Ukrainian
citizen has and we are providing we
already started providing direct
financial support only on minor
repairments for our citizens they're
using the social marked money only for
building materials and for for
construction works as a First Source for
this project we are using arrested many
of bourbon Crusher in Ukraine it's about
500 million U.S dollars and again I hope
that we will stretch a new new project
with cooperation visible bank and thanks
again for for partners for European
commission for European Investment Bank
and ibrd last year we were able to
restore
almost uh
on the on the level of uh of of both
level local level and uh state roads
almost 100 Bridges those Temple
regarding our approach to prioritization
we're working on methodology with World
Bank and I think again we're trying to
analyze complex of factors it's
Financial economical indicators and
impact on social environment indicators
again the most critical right now
we understand that both both directions
is important economical recovery and
again I'm visiting a lot of region and
regions and they see for example how
like the life is continuous it is going
uh in cities on 20 kilometers distance
from Daniels because uh the key critical
comp like Productions in this region is
mines called mines they are working and
normal life I would say normal life
despite in spite of the challenge Etc
it's continue because there are jobs
there are working supermarkets
kindergartens and people they live in
there and vice versa we have the
occupied territories we can repair
everything but in case if we won't have
production there in case if we won't
have jobs here people people won't come
back there
a data-driven policy uh again I will
just mention a few a few things already
mentioned by prime minister digital
restoration ecosystem for accountable
management system dream
uh it's you know we will provide more
details geo-information system for
regional development the unified State
electronic system and the construction
sector e-construction actually we
Implement all projects uh from the
system on National level for the most
complicated construction projects and
the feedback from before that it was the
most corrupted one of the most corrupted
institutions in our country that but
during the last two years
uh very seven only positive feedback
from our business from all business
associations and definitely we need to
expand this system uh into the level
onto the local level and for this the
bill of the low five six five five is
critical and register of damaged and
destroyed property
again we are using on a daily basis
register and again prime minister
mentioned International Register it will
be linked for this register because
already we already fulfilling on a daily
basis register register of damaged
property in cooperation with local
authorities without this we are not
providing any services for local
authorities we are not providing
financing for forestration
uh dream system again I think you you
will have a possibility to to to just to
have more information about it because
on Lobby there are some some streams and
and we can we can present it uh in more
details but again uh the the idea is
just uh to to have in one place uh all
reconstruction management uh ecosystem
that creates a single digital project
Pipeline and ensure transparent and
efficient implementation at the national
Regional level all our partners all our
allies will have access to this system
and again I'd like to emphasize that
screens in the lobby and if like
visitors will have opportunity of time
just to receive more details or on the
website please please do it
uh coordinates for restoration
again as we mentioned it's
uh critical and social infrastructure
Transportation humanitarian and
demanding it's critical but again we can
compare uh in some cases business uh
doing demanding uh much faster much
faster than statistic institutions uh I
think just we need just with this to to
to attract experience from all over the
world because challenges which is which
we are facing right now uh in this
sphere probably are the most one of the
most complicated energy infrastructure
again we are trying to be ready for the
next heating season to prepare our grid
to to to just during to increase
production of electricity to and to
protect our main grid with a reliable
solution and shelters last last year we
did it during during attacks and again
it's already been said many times that
our people our workers they're real
heroes like our soldiers which protect
us protect us on Battlefield
how to speed up restoration again
like there are several ideas but what is
really important uh just to say uh first
of all
I think we always I was I I was I I'm
very often asked uh how uh how we can
help you or how what what is your
priorities or how what is your project
but again we can plan projects we can
discuss and I mean I provide some
figures and we are working with ifis on
daily basis like trying to package all
those schools houses into into new like
projects and step by step we Implement
and some but then it's happening for
example
and on the third day of this strategy we
have to start construction of new
pipeline in order to supply water for
one million people and it cannot be like
it cannot be performed on regular basis
I think we need to discuss during our
donor coordination platform some ideas
how to react on such challenges how what
kind of mechanism we can use in order to
be more fast and to provide
uh like response on such challenges in
much faster way and the economy I I
again I wouldn't spend a lot of time on
future on new Industries uh at least
Let's uh from our ministry from from our
team like we what we are asking let's
discuss together how to react uh and how
what we can how we can support our like
production our business on the occupied
territories because again interest rates
right now in Ukraine like 30 percentage
plus I mean it's impossible just for any
business case to to to just to to walk
to to to to to to receive like positive
results
with such high interest rates to provide
grants probably again it will be one of
the best investments from our joint side
so we will have
more more time to discuss this again
regarding projects uh I wouldn't spend a
lot of time just the key the key thing
that uh 80 of restoration projects are
structured right now we are loans uh
private sector
uh from our point of view
like at this moment uh the most
important things just to start not the
scale of the project of private public
partnership projects based but the key
as they keep for us it's just to start
such a project and we are working
together with IFC with ebrd and
developing preparing concession projects
for example one of the key support on
Black Sea and what we see that there is
interest even right now from five major
companies and they're planning to
participate at the end of this year in
this in this concession contest so again
thank you very much for your time if
it's possible just please switch video
and we'll continue
all right
I remember that day
remember each day
I remember fear
and hatred
I remember the Maria
I remember kharkif Germany
America
[Music]
I remember the words
and that's why I'm here today
[Music]
I am here building peace amidst the
midst of
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm here for you to come back
[Music]
so you have a hole to come back to
I am here for you to love
I'm here to build
kindergartners new new school
hospitals
[Music]
building a lot of Roads
and I'm building one road the road to
Victory
[Music]
I'm here and when I'm asked what I'm
doing here in Ukraine I answer we built
Ukraine
we are all here
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much for that thank you
Deputy Prime Minister for such um such a
powerful expression of what needs to be
done but also what we can do and we have
a very distinguished panel here who will
talk about the various perspectives
um on rebuilding
um I'm my job really is just to be very
very tight time humorous time keeper so
if I could say that
um I will try and be as disciplined as
possible both with my questions and
perhaps with the answers as well so that
we can keep to time and to set an
example I'm going to start with the UK
and if I can turn to our secretary of
state for transport Mark Harper to tell
us a bit about what you see the UK's
role is in supporting the resilience and
recovery of Ukraine's National
infrastructure
uh Sarah thank you will politicians are
not known for their ability to stick to
time but I will do my absolute best and
first of all let me thank uh Deputy
Prime Minister kubrakov who I had the
pleasure of meeting at the G7 transport
ministers meeting in Japan at the
weekend where he set out very clearly
the needs of Ukraine and have the full
support of the G7 colleagues and I'd
like to extend that welcome as well to
finance minister marchenko and all the
panel members and the delegates all of
you here today thank you for joining us
everyone here and people right across
the world admire The Bravery of the
Ukrainian people in standing up to the
murderous invasion of their country
everyone here at Mars the heroism
Farmers turned soldiers Housewives turn
snipers and web designers turn drone
pilots and actually we saw a lot of that
in the video actually Ordinary People
defending their country and the
transformation of an actor not just into
a peacetime president but a war leader
standing up to tyranny
and it's in his and his government and
the Ukrainian people's honor that the UK
has convened uh this meeting today and
tomorrow and we're very proud to do so
but there's another form of Bravery in
Ukraine a form of Bravery not
immediately as clear when I met with uh
Deputy Prime Minister kubrikov's
colleague in Leipzig last month Minister
dercatch he didn't only want to talk
about how Ukraine is going to defeat
Putin nor just about rebuilding his
country after the Cowardly attacks of
Russia but he wanted to talk about
Ukraine's future the plans for clean
energy integrated sustainable and
resilient transport and their plans for
2030 and Beyond the Ukrainian people
don't just have the will to fight they
don't just have the certainty that they
will win but they have the courage to
plan for a better tomorrow and well
Russia remains marred in the past
with lying generals a war criminal Army
and A thieving president Ukraine looks
to a bright future and we stand with
them now providing arms ammunition and
training but will continue to stand with
them as they build that bright future
for the Ukrainian people
the UK government sees measures to
rebuild Ukraine as no less important
than our diplomatic and Military
campaigns transport of course will be a
crucial part of this recovery which is
why following on from the significant
financial support package announced
earlier by the Prime Minister I can
announce new commitments to ensure UK
Ukraine's transport workers are primed
to drive the country's economic recovery
once this conflict is over we will be
funding virtual reality training for
seafarers within Ukraine Maritime
training training for ukrainians here in
the UK and also working to train
Ukrainian air traffic controllers so
that we can get the civil aviation
sector to rebound quickly after the
conflict to enable us to rebuild
Ukraine's economy and that builds on
previous support such as the rail Aid
package which we supplied earlier this
year which I think you saw a bit of in
the video which I had the honor
accompany my own constituency and men
and women that I represent in Parliament
are part of the effort enabling the
Reconstruction of the Ukrainian Railway
system which is essential to enable
their economy to function
but with the World Bank estimating the
Reconstruction cost to top 400 billion
dollars we must mobilize wider
International support including the
private sector that's why this
conference is vital to match Ukraine's
recovery needs with private sector
investment and expertise
to unlock private capital and reassure
investors by de-risking projects and
showing that Ukraine is open for
business and our announcements about the
London Risk insurance Forum framework
are going to be important for that and
to support Ukraine as it reorientates
its economy West rather than East
towards an open Democratic Europe rather
than a closed illiberal Russia towards
the new rather than the olds throughout
Britain will lead by example as we've
done today convening like-minded
Partners to join this Noble effort doing
so will be part of the historic work of
rebuilding a free Ukraine one we're its
citizens can enjoy not only a
hard-fought piece but also a more
prosperous future thank you all very
much indeed for your support I look
forward to coming back here tomorrow to
talk about the work further work we're
doing in the transport sector but for
now thank you very much indeed for what
we're all going to do to support Ukraine
in rebuilding its country
thank you very much
thank you for that
um and if I can now turn to the Minister
of Finance um Ukraine Sergey marchenko
and I would um
welcome you uh perhaps to talk about
um what you see as as the priorities in
um in rebuilding and modernizing and how
you envision the post-war structure of
Ukraine's economy
thank you dear ladies and gentlemen dear
friends colleagues it's a pleasure for
me to be here
and to join such a discussion on
rebuilding the construction of Ukraine
first of all it's a great opportunity
for us
reiterate deep gratitude for all of our
partnering countries which help us to
finance our budget needs at this moment
we fully financed for this year and we
managed to attract for only for this
year 20 billion US Dollars and if we're
talking about starting the war we
managed to attract 51 million U.S
dollars I think it's a great success of
negotiation it's a key message
of our partnering countries to deliver
that we are not alone and we are not
alone only for Budget needs but we are
not alone when we are talking about
Construction
also uh government of Ukraine continues
to hold
overall microeconomic and financial
stability we managed to decrease level
of inflation from 26.6 last year to 15.3
this year we managed to
give necessary incentive for our economy
to strive and to
to revitalize if I may say so
even our partner in IMF estimation
improve our forecast for this year our
GDP will be at least three percent
we have growth at least three percent
also our budget uh in in quite stable
situation we will manage to meet our
plans we also managed to meet our
pre-war revenues Target
if you're talking about reconstruction
the key question we should ask ourselves
and discuss how come
we can manage to bring people of Ukraine
back
and with when we are discussing
different project differences incentive
this should be on our minds it's the
first message how come we can bring our
people back because
[Music]
create and favorable condition in
Ukraine help us to survive help us to
bring our future rather sooner than
later another question we should ask
ourselves we are thinking about
different project restoration
requirement and other kind of
reconstruction
how come we can manage to increase and
to
Ukraine's economic growth it's very
important question we want to restore
our jobs we want to restore our business
to operate in Ukraine we want to attract
investment we want to attract investment
not only force or Wilds but also for
Infusion
and
the last question we should ask
ourselves is this all of projects all of
investment can help us to create better
security in place if it's all of this
question if you have answer yes you can
start invest in Ukraine because it
sounds like we really need it
to be a little bit sobering us like a
minister of finance traditional review
was a very Sovereign persons no nobody
likes us but anyway we should think
about a little bit about existing
a situation in infrastructure we did
together with prime minister with Deputy
Prime Minister kubercow
crucial stuff trying to match our
priorities with possible donors money
with our priorities because it's
something very unusual
in previous slides because we
traditionally were very welcoming for
any money we receive now we are not
if you want to rebuke Ukraine we want to
stick to the priorities which Ukraine
need it first and then to think about
opportunities of other countries we went
to have Ukraine made in Ukraine in place
first
please understand me correctly we went
we want to have made in Ukraine first
and then to think about
expectations of other nations because
it's our country we want to have all
necessary stuff in place we want to
track all those money we want to channel
this money into direction we create
those names and this is not very easy
exercise and I believe we can together
do it any better
thank you very much
thank you
thank you very much and indeed we've
seen today is about mobilizing resources
and our next speaker is extremely
experienced in this
um Anna bayadi Executive Vice President
of the World Bank
um the world bank's been working with
partners and has assessed Ukraine's
recovery needs over the coming years
um what are the most striking things for
you
well thank you so very much and let me
just start by saying how pleased I am to
be here at this important event let me
thank the government of Ukraine and also
thank the government of the United
Kingdom for convening us and thank you
for your question which I have reflected
upon what are some of the most striking
things that we have seen and learned in
assessing Ukraine's needs and early
recovery well striking is of course
first and foremost that we have a brutal
war in Europe caused by Invasion by one
country and to another in 2022 and it
seems really to me still unbelievable to
comprehend that secondly striking is
that we have a humanitarian suffering
that is enormous just to put it in
perspective the World Bank estimates
that Ukraine's poverty has gone from
about five percent before the war to
about 25 now
the other striking fact is and it was
mentioned that the Reconstruction needs
of Ukraine after one year of war and of
course now now we are one and a half
year into war was estimated uh by us the
European commission uh un and you
government of Ukraine at 411 billion
dollars that is two times GDP of Ukraine
in 2021 that's striking and the final
issue of course is that the impacts of
Russia's war on Ukraine are felt in
Ukraine but also globally in the form of
inflation tighter Financial conditions
and great uncertainty but what is also
striking is Ukraine's resilience and we
hear about it and of course what we see
is government and services are ongoing
infrastructure services are restored
budget is well managed and executed
reforms are even being designed and
implemented in the most recent remit law
is something the World Bank Bank really
supports and I wanted to just illustrate
a few findings from two surveys that we
have undertaken recently that also shows
the resilience the first one is a
monthly listening to Ukraine survey that
looks at mod the monitoring of delivery
of essential social services that are
delivered with the support of our peace
project in Ukraine and this is results
from April and May over 90 percent of
Public Service workers have experienced
no disruption in receiving payment on
time others only with a slight delay 97
percent of Pensions have been paid
without disruption 92 percent of
school-aged children are enrolled two
out of five receive fully remote
learning of course much higher in areas
where there are hostilities and most
people report
the health clinics are open even in
regions under hostilities there are also
some areas that give us a glimpse into
what we need to pay attention to around
a quarter of those employed before the
war are reported to have lost jobs many
report that they have irregular jobs or
are working to lower salaries and six
out of 10 surveyed reported their
household is receiving a pension this
means that there are a lot of elderly in
Ukraine and we can also expect learning
losses because in the areas that are
suffering from the hostilities there are
a lot of Children online we also did a
survey of firms that looked at 2 000
domestic firms and 80 multinational
firms and again of course firms have
suffered Revenue loss and employment
reduction but four out of five firms 80
percent have continued to stay open only
four percent have permanently closed and
this is because firms have adapted
product mix Market ICT location the
other very encouraging fact is that
International companies have remained
committed to working in Ukraine Ukraine
and the World Bank have a very
long-standing partnership we adjusted
very quickly to support the work context
at this point in time we have mobilized
30 billion dollars for Ukraine a lot of
this is coming through Partners through
the World Bank and about 23 of this has
been dispersed we provide support to all
essential Social Services through the
budget and are now also working on
critical projects in areas such as
health uh transport energy Agriculture
and housing and what I'd like to maybe
just finish with this what do we see as
most essential now well we really need
to focus on tangible results we heard it
this morning and I I'm really impressed
the 2023 budget is in much better shape
actually than the 2022 budget was this
is very good news and it's really thanks
to the good execution of the Ministry of
Finance and of course International
Development Partners but we also really
need to focus now on the investment
projects they also need funding they
need execution and they need support we
also need to make sure we stay
coordinated Among Us and of course also
Ukraine within Ukraine and we need to
make sure we think recreatively with the
private sector I was encouraged to hear
about war insurance we need to think
about leveraging and we need to think
about guarantees and we need to stay
United as a community for Ukraine and
with Ukraine and for this I really
welcome this conference and I will
finally say that we must always remember
that our steadfast support to Ukraine is
by for Ukraine but it's also an
investment in global Prosperity thank
you thank you thank you very much
see the extraordinary to hear of
progress even within those conditions
and we turn now to
um Lars Locker Rasmussen the foreign
minister of Denmark and if I could ask
you how do you think we engage the
private sector and secure a long-term
whole of society engagement in the
support of Ukraine
thank you and thank you for that
question first of all I would also like
to Echo a warm thank you to UK for
hosting this year's Ukraine recovery
conference and I also want to emphasize
our strong commitment and support to
Ukraine which cannot lose momentum and
and that's perhaps a bridge builder to
answering your question because engaging
the private sector and Civil Society is
also about ensuring long-term commitment
to Ukraine because our strongest
stronghold our democracy is potentially
the also our weakness I mean
it's very clear that the strategy in
criminal these days is to wait and see
whether Western the Allies the friends
to Ukraine will lose our patience
so we need to mystically strong support
and by engaging civil society and
private sector we can do more in Ukraine
and we can engage more voters honestly
speaking which will ensure long-term
commitment
so a few Reflections about our concrete
experiences
first about how to make an inclusive
process in line with what what I just
said in in Denmark we have created a
Ukraine fund
with strong political support in the
parliament everybody is on board
this year alone it is around 2 billion
Euro
most of it of course military support
because that's the most important thing
right now but we can't wait for the last
bullet to be fired before we start
reconstruction so we have allocated
around 100 billion euros to
reconstruction efforts
and we have established a sounding board
or Advisory board or whatever you would
like to call it to ensure a whole of
society effort and we have brought a
variety of actors to the table to
discuss the daily support to Ukraine so
that's one important thing
and secondly you could ask how to ensure
the essential engagement of the private
sector both the short-term and long term
and and we have found and and this is
not rocket science but we have found
that companies face two significant
challenges in the efforts to engage in
Ukraine and first of course a major risk
of of losses in connection with exports
to and in and investments in Ukraine and
and secondly and I think equally
important a lack of information about
projects Market opportunities and
relevant Ukrainian Partners so it's not
easy I mean to do business with Ukraine
these days and to help to overcome these
challenges we have launched a loan and
guarantee scheme in Denmark's export and
investment fund and with this fund we
have engaged right now more than 150
Danish companies and private funds
in in
in concrete projects in in Ukraine it is
of course still early days but so far
newly funded private sector projects are
supporting more than 1 000 jobs in
Ukraine uh short-term credits loans and
guarances are important tools to sustain
economic activities here now and of
course this is just you know the very
first small steps towards to watch more
transformative efforts we will need
massive investments from International
financial institutions and support for
the Ukrainian Banking and insurance
sectors but we are on our way and then
finally I would say just a few words
about the regional approach which I also
think is important to to keep the
private sector and the Civil Society on
board because we responded positively
and accepted the invitation from
president zielinski last year to take a
special responsibility for
reconstruction because life
and it have led to a situation where
it's much more visible I mean
with that approach it comes with many
advantages
it contributes to a broad public
ownership and it allows for direct
coordination with national and local
authorities in Ukraine
um we have had the Mayan book live in in
Denmark on several locations already
we have had business communities in biku
live we are planning to establish a
representation a kind of satellite from
our Embassy in Keith and Michael live so
this Regional approach is also I think
an important stepping stone
to
to actually do something
so I mean that could be perhaps three
takeaways from the Danish experience and
then finally on a personal note I mean
uh
I must say and we discussed it here in
the panel I am so impressed about the
Ukrainian leadership I mean I have been
Minister for like 15 years so together
prime minister Finance Minister it's a
tough job but bearing in mind that you
are fighting a war
and you are making you know
progress and reforms and we are pushing
for transparency and anti-corruption and
sound fiscal policy and and then this uh
huge challenge link to reconstruction
it is amazing
and I just want to say that on a
personal note
[Applause]
um it's proving its worth uh just now so
we we take our place in that and also
this sort of innovative approaches
um that that we that we can take and
that Denmark is
um already doing so we turn now to Verna
Hoya uh president of the European
Investment Bank
um and the question uh for you is really
how can Ukraine evolve its economic
structure to attract investment and pave
the way for immediate and sustained
growth drawing on relevant lessons from
earlier EU enlargement support
well thank you very much and thanks to
the organizers for having us here in
London it's a privilege and a great
opportunity and I would like to thank
the Ukrainian colleagues and I would
like to underline what Las Vegas just
said it's amazing what these people in
Ukraine are presently doing their
perseverance their their resolve but
this is also true for the leaders and
without them it wouldn't work so
congratulations on this
what is key and this is obvious
it is not only weapons which will decide
whether this war will be won or not it
will also be the economic resilience
this is which is presently shown in the
remarkable way all the way from from
text collection to to continuous
production under difficult circumstances
so uh what we do today to support
investment
will make Ukraine stronger within the EU
tomorrow and I underline within the EU
because I see this guy over there as my
future Governor as the Finance Minister
of Ukraine he would be the governor of
the European Investment Bank nowadays
so what we do now will lower the bill
tomorrow
the more we wait the higher the bill for
reconstruction will be one day so that
we better get started now and not wait
until the Inc underpiece treaty is dry
that might take some time so let's not
underestimate the ukrainians like
vladimirovich did because he thought he
could do it easily that is obviously not
the case and he has made the other
miscalculation that he thought the West
would fall apart immediately once he has
crossed the border our institutions the
European Investment Bank stopped our
business in Ukraine in in Russia in 2014
because we said he will not stop on
Crimea this will go on and this was why
we were pretty well prepared to do our
job there
when we look back over the last decades
no process in Europe has been as
powerful as the accession of the
countries of the former Soviet Union and
the there was a pact to the European
Union right and when I visited as a
European affairs minister said the 90s
the Baltic states for instance I would
have never dreamed or dreamed that one
day they will be successful successful
within the European Union and they are
and through cradle as well because some
people must get rid of the idea that
there is some developing country joining
the European Union with huge problems
bringing with themselves no this is
going to be a strong economy not just
agriculture but also when it comes to
technology look at what the Ukrainian
people in Western Europe are presently
experiences experiencing when they see
how far behind the schedule we in
Western Europe are when it comes to
digitalization and the use of the
electronic means for instance so let's
let's welcome the uh the Ukraine as a
strengthening of the European you Union
once they're in
I'm convinced the Ukrainian economy can
evolve massively by considering
reconstruction accession and integration
together applying EU standards and
everything they are doing which is the
case but also bearing in mind that this
course requires a lot of buy-in
I'm sure that the government can again
surprise us very much on line and
accelerate on aligning with the uh EU on
rule of law whether we have heard about
dream before is the dream and if we
already see the fruits of this and this
is extremely encouraging because this is
a reassuring message this is the
confidence building measure for
investment in Ukraine so through lending
and technical assistance we as EU Bank
are working in close partnership with
our partners but of course particularly
with the European commission there is by
the way no room for competition among
multilateral development Banks there is
so much room for synergies and
cooperation we need to do this together
today
for you with the ministry of restoration
to strengthen our cooperation on
reconstruction recovery we have a huge
pipeline of projects if we get the
guarantees in order to bring this into
place we can do much much more and last
but not least we will later sign an
important agreement with the European
commission to launch the EU for business
guarantee facility to improve access to
finance for smes in Ukraine and other
countries of the European unions is a
partnership thank you very much
foreign
for that reminder that economic
resilience as as well as Weapons
um how much that matters and also the
the excellent example of the Baltic
states in EU accession and how we can
look forward beyond that so we've been
talking about the recovery of Ukraine
being sort of visibly about
infrastructure uh Troy Rudd is the CEO
of aircom best acronym of the day which
is a major Global infrastructure
consulting firm and I wonder if you
could tell us how you are engaging
um the private sector to help address
Ukraine's immediate recovery needs and
from your experience how can we make
support to Ukraine's early recovery even
more targeted and impactful for the long
term great thank you very much and first
before I start I would like to thank the
organizers the government of the UK and
the government of the Ukraine for
bringing us together and having this
discussion and as always already said
Thank you to the leadership ship of the
Ukrainian government for being frankly
so brave and leading in such an
extraordinary difficult time
um as an organization private
organization we did not start with any
presence in the Ukraine prior to the
invasion
but we immediately supported the Ukraine
by first and I'll say immediately within
days closing down our business in Russia
and exiting the country and since then
we have many people in Europe that have
been individually supporting the Ukraine
and the people from the Ukraine and we
as an organization have taken a strong
position to continue to do that
now with respect to your question about
the the acceleration of the investment
in the recovery or in infrastructure I
really think there's two things from our
experience that I would point out
first of all there's been a discussion
about the magnitude of the recovery and
it's always talked about in terms of
dollars
but you have to think about the
mobilization that's got to take place
the mobilization of people to come from
other countries when the recovery gets
into full force and the impact on Supply
chains what actually has to be mobilized
to make this happen beyond the dollars
there's no question there's the
commitment the financial commitment and
the quit commitment and the will to do
this
but if you think about how do you
mobilize
in the face of so much that has to
happen in such a short period of time
and think about all the stakeholders
that are involved the stakeholders the
people of Ukraine the decision makers
within the government this decision
makers with other governments that are
participating or within Banks
the amount of stakeholder engagement is
extraordinary and so I think that what
we've learned from our past experience
is bringing a programmatic approach to
this
or you have the opportunity to lay out
the objectives of the stakeholders
Baseline what you need to accomplish and
settle clear Milestones that obviously
adapt over time but then it gives you
the ability to create transparency and
accountability against achieving those
goals so that's the first and I think
the most important thing is taking a
program programmatic approach and I can
say it on behalf of our organization we
think we will help bring that to the
table a programmatic approach again to
the Reconstruction of the country
the second important point is again in
terms of the mobilization
it's imperative that we have governments
and private sector come together but
governments to create a safe and
efficient environment so that private
sector can move people and goods into
the country and what I mean by that is
creating government to government
relationships
that allow for that to happen so
effectively things like extending the
licenses of Engineers from other
countries into the Ukraine without
having to be re-licensed
extending the opportunity for people to
come in and out and across the border
right migrating to two projects and two
programs
and also creating an opportunity so that
Goods to support the construction and
reconstruction can come across the
border and again this isn't just a
central government-to-government
relationship it's a a relationship that
governed all all forms of government
whether it's local or Municipal so that
again those goods can come into the
projects when they need to be
efficiently and quickly
so that we can expedite the
Reconstruction of the country and again
I I can't I can't I can't tell you how
important and there are great examples
of have been done in the past those
country to Country agreements that
really open up the opportunity for
really the efficient delivery of the
recovery
thank you very much indeed for that
it's very good to consider not just what
needs to be done but how and we're going
to turn now to Akim Steiner who's
administrative United Nations
development program and you've just
returned from Ukraine and so you've met
people directly affected by the war as
well as key officials including the
prime minister so how can the
International Community best support the
government to ensure an early recovery
and how is the United Nations family
having an impact on the ground
thank you very much Sarah and thank you
also to our co-hosts thank you for
bringing us together and indeed talking
about recovery can take many forms you
just alluded to another one I think we
heard a lot about systems and ecosystems
that you are building Deputy Prime
Minister I think the first challenge
that you have faced in thinking about
recovery in the midst of a crisis
is that precisely you have to take a
systemic approach which is not easy
given the daily survival challenges that
I face but let me just say having spent
some days in traveling across Ukraine
last week
I met your senior officials I met Mayors
I met the men and women who basically
had to flee it a few hours notice and
are now trying to go back to the places
they call home but what they find is
shattered homes
I met the brave men and women who are
now on the front lines of what has
become one of the largest minefields in
the world Ukraine with unexploded
ordinance and having to try and clear
for example a residential area outside
Kiev European which I spent the morning
at first of all of the mines that
prevent you from going back then the
rubble that has to be removed getting
both the local Administration the
equipment the expertise to do all this
and the financing
recovery colleagues I think really is
not an abstract concept right now there
were some when we met in Lugano who said
how can you talk about recovering
reconstruction when you're in the middle
of a war if you speak to those tenants
that I met if you meet the small and
medium-scale entrepreneurs the men and
women who are actually the backbone of
Ukraine's economy right now
and you speak to them and you hear how
they lost everything became internally
displaced people live in another part of
the country right now have to rebuild
their businesses how little money can
actually make an absolute difference in
starting again it is these hundreds of
thousands if not millions of small
Enterprises that you and your prime
minister when I met him also highlighted
as a top priority recovery
reconstruction is not only physical it's
the social infrastructure we already
heard this morning about hospitals about
schools it's also about the many injured
that are now in hospitals that have to
recover I spent time in a hospital
complex in leviv and learned about the
challenge of just producing enough
Prosthetics finding people who can
produce them setting up businesses can
actually provide an input at that moment
but let me briefly say so as you also
said I'm here on behalf of the Secretary
General this morning representing him he
could not be here but he wanted to send
it very strong and unequivocal message
of commitment on behalf of the United
Nations I'm joined by the resident
coordinator of the United Nations
country team here many of our agencies
who are working in Ukraine right now and
some of us for decades undp has been a
partner in Ukraine for over 20 years
others were mobilized for example
through the humanitarian response
immediately after those attacks began
just this year 5.4 million people have
already been supported by the
humanitarian response that the United
Nations its NGO partners are rolling out
our challenge ever remains that saving
lives is something you have to do as
part of also thinking about recovery but
the humanitarian appeal right now is
only 25 funded we do emergency responses
for example to the kahov cadan the
difficulty of trying to bring immediate
support in such a catastrophic event was
a challenge but humanitarian agencies
local ngos local authorities join forces
many people were struggling to survive
the immediate disaster the question now
is can we quickly help the government
also to rebuild and help the people to
recover
and certainly the UN development system
with 24 agencies and over 3 000 staff
invested in virtually all operas that
are currently not occupied by Russia
helping local authorities to plan to do
assessments Anna spoke about the damage
assessments that we do together with the
World Bank the European Union to support
the government the human impact
assessment that was just published last
week to also draw attention to what is
happening to people's livelihoods the
loss of income the food insecurity that
is being faced the challenge for
government to mount the kind of social
safety nets this is the United Nations
commitment to working with our
colleagues in Ukraine and as a partner
with many of those who have you just
heard speaking and on whom we also rely
to bring the resources that allow us to
be truly a voice for Recovery while
lives are being saved livelihoods are
being created thank you
thank you
thank you very much indeed such an
important discussion we're also as I
said on a tight time scale and I know
that Mr uh Rasmussen you will have to
leave there's going to be a rush from
the stage at one but if you if you need
to leave between speakers
do and uh in the meantime we're going to
turn next for a valuable perspective on
the Baltic states and the EU response to
maintaining economic stability in the
region
[Music]
who is the executive vice president for
an economy commissioner for trade at the
European commission
um and I wonder if I can ask you that
the Ukraine and the EU have been clear
on its future as a as a member State
what is the eu's view of the private
sector's role in recovery and how will
the reform link to membership status
Galvanize this
yeah a good afternoon everyone well
first of all uh thank you for this
opportunity to speak at Ukraine recovery
conference
on the future of Ukraine as it has been
stated also by President Ferdinand
earlier today the future of Ukraine is
in European union and just yesterday
European commission put forward a
Ukraine facility was
50 billion euros to cover the time
period from 2024 to
2027 and this facility has
three main pillars one is of course a
public financing which we are going to
provide for Ukraine both to maintain a
macro Financial stability but also for
Ukraine's recovery needs and there we of
course hope that this
eu's initiative coming with a sizable
medium term package will also help other
donors to mobilize their support
but another important aspect of this
package is how to mobilize a private
sector to to support Ukraine's recovery
and that's actually one of the topics of
today's
conference including the question of War
Insurance because clearly in current
circumstances for businesses to go to
Ukraine to invest to
do a different kind of economic
activities the question is about
covering the country risk and coverings
War insurance and that's why it's
important that ebrd is now coming with
this initiative on a pilot
scheme concerning warring Assurance we
are going to sign as a agreement to work
on this about him later today to cover
the estimated Finance needs so European
Union is going to be one of the
supporters of this initiative it's also
important for
companies to get involved to how expert
export credit guarantee schemes and we
are currently uh working on the power
project of export credits to Ukraine and
I also would like to mention several
European Investment Bank initiatives EU
for Ukraine initiative to support
infrastructure reconstruction
address priority investment needs also
ensure business support so we'll be
supporting European commission will be
supporting this package financially with
100 million euros guarantee and today we
will be also signing two other
agreements on support for smes in
Ukraine so clearly this
support for a business will be important
part of Ukraine reconstruction effort
and finally the third aspect of our
Ukraine facility is that we link
together Investments and reforms and
reforms which are linked with Ukraine's
past towards EU access
so the idea of the plan is that Ukraine
would prepare a medium-term
reconstruction plan in a cooperation
with the EU in cooperation with other
donors and this plan would bring
together necessary Investments and
reforms not only to help with
reconstruction but indeed also help with
a green and digital
Transformations and economy and to help
with the reforms necessary for Ukraine
towards joining the EU thank you thank
you very much indeed
thank you for that um and we we've seen
today International
institutions stepping up uh we're next
going to hear from the oecd and Matty
yes uh Corman on uh if you could uh tell
us a little bit about what the oecd has
been focusing on to support the
Ukrainian recovery and reform effort
well and thank you very much sir and
thank you for inviting me alongside for
hosting this important event since we
last met and we've continued to work
with the government of Ukraine with our
members in the Europe European Union
International
Partners providing support to Ukraine
and you know we have also welcomed
Ukraine as a prospective member of the
oecd which started an initial accession
dialogue with Ukraine earlier this year
we opened an oecd office in Kiev which
is designed to further strengthen our
cooperation on the ground and further
strengthen our impacts on the ground but
the most important reason development
has been the decision to enter into an
agreement with Ukraine on the
establishment of a formal four-year like
oecd country program for Ukraine that
program is designed to provide a
structured approach to our reform and
institutional support to Ukraine across
the public policy Spectrum with the
objective to achieve increased adherence
by Ukraine to oecd standards and best
practices and also to boost its
participation in Norway City policy
bodies it's it's a program which
reflects Ukraine's reform priorities and
it's designed in particular to support
efforts to attract a quality private
sector investment in support of the
recovery and generally to help optimize
the strength and the quality of the
recovery just very quickly in terms of
areas of focus first on helping to
ensure transparent a fair and effective
regulatory administrative and legal
processes which is all about helping to
provide provide certainty and boost
confidence as part of boosting a private
sector investment we're working with the
state regulatory service of Ukraine to
improve a regulatory policy making and
further simplify administrative
processes we're promoting sound
governance of state-owned Enterprises
supporting the effectiveness of
Ukraine's tax policy Administration
we've also provided support and training
for tax officials judges and law
enforcement staff the National
anti-corruption Bureau of Ukraine which
brings me to the second point which is
that we're working to make further
progress with anti-corruption and
integrity measures our country program
involves analysis and capacity building
to support Ukraine's adherence to the
oecd anti-bribery convention to which
Ukraine has recently become a
participant currently we're conducting a
review of Ukraine's anti-corruption
action plan based on International
standards and best practice bench marks
including with respect for corruption
prevention and criminal responsibility
we focused on improving competition and
encouraging investment in the energy
sector it's been noted that Ukraine has
and continues to do an amazing job in
maintaining and restoring electricity
supplies disrupted by Russia's atrocious
war of aggression but of course you know
next Friday we will launch the Orange
City Market study of the electricity
sector in Ukraine which provides
practical recommendations on longer-term
reforms for the period after the war
again to improve regulatory stability
enhance the functioning of wholesale and
Retail electricity markets and also to
in to accelerate the integration into EU
electricity markets fourth we're
focusing on supporting efficient
well-connected and sustainable
infrastructure with a sound policy
framework for Ukraine to leverage a
public-private Partnerships and
concessions for infrastructure
ultimately again to boost investment
fifth we're focusing on
supporting growth and recovery of
Ukraine's small and medium-sized
businesses with a specific
policy review focused on Ukraine's SME
sector based on the European Union's
small business act across Dimensions
such as access to finance and
procurement opportunities and also
developing advice on supporting the
adoption of digital tools by SMS there's
much more that I could talk about but in
the interest of time let me just say in
closing that of course you know as we
work to do our bid focus on our areas of
comparative
opportunity to make the best possible
contribution we will of course continue
to coordinate closely and work closely
with all International partners
bilaterally and also through the
multi-agency donor coordination platform
and thank you very much
thank you very much indeed thank you
it's a great accent to hear in the
Coalition of the committed um I'm afraid
we're going to have to lose I think two
ministers now um and Minister moshenko
and and Mr kubrikov um to other meetings
um but we still have some key speakers
left so um we're going to move on to the
minister for foreign affairs of Norway
um and you can uh vitfelt and uh the
question of for you would be that this
year
um six billion pound Ukraine Support
Program announced by Norway uh shows the
long-term commitment made by your
country to Ukraine are you able to say
something about the focus on early
recovery yes thank you Sarah some weeks
ago I participated in that recovery
conference in Odessa together with my
colleagues my Nordic political
colleagues and also culeba and all those
local politicians elected by their own
people in free elections in Ukraine
really inspired us all I think to to
look ahead
to build a stronger and more resilient
Ukrainian democracy and a stronger
Ukrainian economy
but we know very well that money and
Good Will is not enough
so I really appreciate this invitation
to this important discussion
because reconstruct reconstruction
efforts must be coordinated
and they must be based on also local
needs
example
on humanitarian characters
not based on local demands but rather on
the individual donors country and what
they are willing to provide from their
own storages
and how the recipients
are forced to buy goods from the donors
that tells more about the donor
than the willingness
to assist the result is often that the
local markets are totally destroyed
that local economy and local businesses
suffer
so we are acutely aware of this when we
are implementing our largest assistant
program ever
and through the Norwegian assistance
program we focus on first firstly early
recovery rebuilding infrastructure such
as electricity system and bridges
secondly making sure that Ukrainian
services such as schools and hospitals
can can remain open
thirdly finding ways to strengthen
Ukrainian businesses Innovation and
Entrepreneurship
fourthly strengthening the Ukrainian
democracy and legal system and finally
of course
Military Support
in many ways Ukraine is very different
from other humanitarian efforts but we
must make sure that we don't repeat
mistakes from past
when providing assistance to Ukraine we
must make sure that local businesses
will benefit
therefore we announce today a donation
of 25 million euro to provide War
insurances and guarantee mechanisms so
companies are willing to invest
this is a part of the 7 billion Euro
Norwegian program you've had to earlier
in your question of Sarah
you know what this business are asking
for a reliable legal system
commitment to anti-corruption
and burden sharing when it comes to
Investments risks
and Ukraine has already accomplished a
lot
the willingness to fight corruption
and the decentralization reforms I think
are positive steps
and I will also thank the ebrd and the
bull Bank Anna for the very good
cooperation
and also the coordination for the EU
civilian mechanisms and I'm very pleased
to see so many Innovation companies hit
today because I think that private
companies really demonstrate that we are
in there all of us for the Long Haul
thank you
thank you very much for being and thank
you for underlining it's both the
ambition and and the values um of in
your commitment so our final panelist
um it's a former officer in the U.S Navy
civil engineer court so understands both
Logistics and urgency he's uh Bob
brigada and he's here as CEO of Jacobs
which serves critical markets um as we
know in global infrastructure Advanced
manufacturing and National Security so
if I may ask you the question of how
will the private public and non-profit
sector rebuild a resilient Ukraine that
prospers even in an ever-changing and
unpredictable world and what conditions
are necessary for this recovery
Sarah thank you for having me uh I think
it's being last it's either no one is
listening or everybody is listening
because they want to go but it is uh it
is very uh it's great to be here and uh
and also very inspiring said I was a
former naval officer I have witnessed
firsthand reconstruction of war-torn
areas where
um the result the the resilience of an
International Community coming together
uh as one uh what I saw this morning and
what we've seen all along is very very
inspiring so thank you you know when
when Minister cooperkov put the first
slide up and it talked about just the
magnitude and we've heard a lot of
numbers this morning about the magnitude
from a monetary standpoint from just a
sheer volume perspective you know as the
uh as the leader of Jacobson PA
Consulting
seventy thousand people globally twenty
thousand people here in in Europe uh
with deep expertise and infrastructure
and clean energy and and everything that
uh that the country needs
um I I thought to myself
important but that's not why we're all
here uh that's only one step uh because
it's not about us it's about the people
of the Ukraine and so when we really
think about what outcome are we trying
to drive in the Reconstruction of the
Ukraine uh what we believe it is is the
the self-actualization of the Ukrainian
people to be a part of the International
Community and and so you know if you
start with that outcome then all of the
interfaces in the interdependence of
what we do becomes even that much more
important and what we were kind of
reflecting on as a team when we were
thinking about what we would say today
is there was an American psychologist
back in the 50s named Abraham love and
maslov came up with a uh a profile it's
called the hierarchy of needs and uh and
how each of these needs for people build
upon each other and at the bottom of
that pyramid is the physiological needs
Energy Water food you can start to see
the parallels here
the next is security is do I live in a
secure environment and then with the
physiological needs and the secure needs
things like love and esteem and and
respect start to come and and if you
compare it to what we're talking about
at a global scale uh and then at the top
of that pyramid is self-actualization
and so the the interface between the
private sector the public sector the
non-profits I really believe it's the
interdependency and not getting too
caught up in what we're the experts at
but really understanding what are we
trying to achieve
and I believe the the environment that
needs to be in place clearly peace needs
to be in place but we're gonna we're as
as the minister talked about we're
already doing so much now even with the
the challenges that the Ukrainian people
are having
um but I think all of us need to think
about a recovery-based ecosystem for
sustainable uh growth and prosperity for
the country of Ukraine so thank you
thanks for having me
thank you very much the EK system of
recovery we'll leave it there but thank
you so much um for uh this uh this this
terrific panel and I think we finished
on time so people can have lunch and uh
thank you especially um to minister
marchenko and Mr cooperkov thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you
and it's a 2 p.m 2 p.m start
[Music]
changing
tonight
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I don't know
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
sure
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
well it's off the bubble yeah
[Music]
thank you
yeah that's as tight as I can do it
yep that's good
[Music]
I have one little moment
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
position
s
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
juices the session is about to begin
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
please thank you seats the session is
about to begin
what's up
[Music]
so
vision yeah I can hear him fine and
obviously I can speak to you
welcome back everyone ministers your
excellencies delegations all
distinguished guests we're now going to
move to a plenary three we talked
earlier about the immediate recovery
needs of Ukraine this session is going
to turn its focus on building the
foundations for Ukraine's longer term
recovery the actions needed to support
Ukraine's ambition to modernize its
economy and the critical role that
private finance will play in order to
deliver this and I'm delighted that this
session is going to be introduced via a
live link from Kiev by Andre yarmac
Ukrainian President zelenski's Chief of
Staff thank you
foreign
dear colleagues
I Believe In Hope
I believe in a belief this is a worth of
the evictions character of the famous TV
series said lasso then it became a
symbol of faith in the heavy future
and your less real people ready to share
this principle
such people are increasing every day and
necessary people gathered here today
the people who believe in Ukraine and I
thank everyone
I would like to personally thank the
governments and the people of great
reason from the first day of the
large-scale invasion your country has
been a leader in support of Ukraine
other partners to take more decisive
actions
Ukrainian people will always remember
this and I will explain why this is
important as our president is noted we
intend to implement five real concepts
for the building sustainable peace
through immunity stability growth
security and democracy this is the
answer to many questions of that we've
learned to do together with our partners
what is the answer to the questions of
how it should be done
first timely and efficiency
criteria we should uh National while
considering our reactions
energy and social infrastructure and
housing for the lives of our people
however with the purpose of today's
conference it is not only to discuss the
Urgent needs for the recovery of Ukraine
we have to focus both a general
long-term stress on this specific
projects as a result we should get a
package of steps to create the most
attractive conditions for the private
Universe investors
[Music]
so our strategies goal is to build a new
modern industry we new complex
Productions in every different industry
in very different Industries
what is why we invite business from all
continents to Ukraine for example in
international collaborations what we
take their Productions out of Russia or
China will be able to restart them in
Ukraine
this is the circularation
with no doubt to be mutually beneficial
we rules we plan to live or can be put
into two worlds European standards
we strive to join the European Union as
quickly as possible
however our tasks regarding internal
transformation are much more ambitions
we must be attracted as possible for
Investments
so we plan in the development of our
Logistics
Financial scientific and educational
infrastructure
[Music]
systemic internal change
we have already made significant
problems
we are going on despite the world this
Lord in the days of the wild set of
reforms from strengthening
to judicious
[Music]
to simplifications of the tax system
transparency and crashes Zero Tolerance
are key Rewards
why smoke Ukrainian economy will be able
to support a strong Army to prevent
similar large-scale immigrations in
Europe
so it is the common enters of our
partners and us
on the other hand we need security for
reality Economic Development
investors from all of the worlds should
confidentially come to Ukraine to ensure
this brain must become
[Music]
membership
we only said the challenges we Face are
understanding so we have to work in the
same and presented peace and quality and
all that will give us here and they have
ukrainians everyone their ability to
deal with the such challenges effective
Russia is draining the world into their
right past and ukrainians are focused on
the future so together with the other
countries we must believe a safe and
uncomfortable world for ourselves and
the future Generations
glory to Ukraine thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
thank you very much bringing endorsement
of Ukraine the future and I'm delighted
to welcome onto the stage now and the
first Deputy Prime Minister of Ukraine
minister of the economy
um Julia Sabria denka thank you
[Applause]
thank you
dear guests their colleagues
my best greetings to you and I'm glad to
see you all here as I think it's one of
the most
important panel because we are going to
discuss the future Ukraine
and today we're all stand on the right
side of the history I'm absolutely sure
in this and together we stand for the
better better future and not only for
the better future of Ukraine but for the
better future of Europe and the whole
world in general
and we have a clear vision of how we're
going to see Crane in 10 years
so we see Ukraine as a first of all as a
food security provider for at least 600
million people across the globe
a reliable source of green energy in
Europe
Ukraine will provide up to 15 of eu's
green energy
we consider ourselves one one of the
leader in the green industrial
transition
a reliable supplier of a critical
materials and natural resources
of course the eastern border of NATO and
the Arsenal of the Free World
we envisioned a boom of startups and
Entrepreneurship
a place for professional and Social
Development and of course we are
integral in the integral component of
the EU infrastructure Network so Ukraine
is a safe
economically and business driven
there is no abstract concept but
specific and independent reforms and
programs
so obviously Ukrainian recovery will be
one of the most ambitious projects for
reconstruction for the in the 21st
century
Ukraine's recovery Market is estimated
at 500 up to 900 billion US Dollars most
of this should be financed and is
financed by the private sector
why will Ukraine become the next next
investment magnet for the world
because business activity in Ukraine
means long-term and stable benefit
access to the EU and G7 markets
optimal location for production and
headquarters and freedom
to Foster Economic Development and the
digitalization
we have set a very strategic
goal to get and reach GDP growth up to 1
trillion US dollar
we need to have a strong Army over 500
000 military
at the same time we must develop the
social sphere who must develop Education
Health Care
economic growth will enable
funding of these sectors
without critical burden on the budget
so we don't want to hit the business
when we are committed to the principles
of economic freedom therefore the role
of the state will in 10 years will
significantly decrease
by 2033 we aim to decrease the budget
ready to gcp up to
25 percent
we estimate the local market for
Ukraine's reconstruction development to
be over 509 500 billion over the next 20
years
in addition the replacement of Russian
and Chinese exported to you countries
can provide the market
over 200 billion annually to achieve
that we will have well different goals
and strategies in key sectors such as
agriculture energy industry and others
Ukraine holds a strategy strategic
advantage in this industry and their
Advance advancement will cater to need
to Ukraine Europe and the global market
so let's start with the first one is a
green energy resources Ukraine has
significantly
energy potential and can become an
important energy exported to the EU and
the flagship of the green industrial
transition we need to produce
700 terawatt hours
of electricity to meet our domestic
needs and external demand
in addition to electricity Ukraine will
become a reliable supply of green
gitrogen and as well as biomethane
produced from agricultural based
green industrial transition alongside
the development of the green generation
we will also ensure green transition of
other industrial sectors
we aim to produce
green steel aluminum and fertilizer and
provide them with Green Logistics
environmentally friendly electric Rail
and Reverb transport
food security food security provider for
600 million people on the planet
becoming the largest private label
supplier in EU
trade networks and contributing the
global food security
a critical materials Ukraine can become
the center of Europe for Mining and
production of materials necessary for
the development of Innovative
Technologies
Ukraine has results of 12 priority
strategic minerals our goal is to set up
a full production cycle not just expand
the extraction of raw materials but to
be able to become a supplier of lithium
batteries fuel fuel elements for nuclear
power plants and other end products
of course EU infrastructure integration
they Integra to integrate with the
European union we need to redirect our
trade flows from the post-soviet network
and to to look the trans European routes
our goal is to connect
all regional centered by highways
High-Speed Rail and build a modern
system for the use of Air transport the
main green logistic will be Rail and
River Transport
all Urban transport will also will be
switched to electricity transport
during the following panels you will see
the sector discussed in more details
this is how
we see economic development for the next
10 years
of course we will do whatever it takes
us to make this Vision a reality
and if we do not succeed
we can lose our serenity
so that's why two main prerequisites for
this is NATO and you
and it's something that can provide us
security Market success access and
International
institutional reform
also Ukraine will create a variable
condition for business cooperation both
now and after Ukraine's victory
we're realized perfectly well that it
cannot be achieved without structural
reforms
anti-corruption reforms rule of law
the implementation of these reforms for
us is a matter of attracting investment
we aim to foster a farewell business
climate and to ensure access to
Affordable capital
additional to this we are working right
now on a competitive tax system and
focus on developing a modern labor
market to meet challenges of the
post-war recovery of Ukraine
of course to aim this ambitious goal we
need people who are well willing to make
it happen
we will create conditions for ukrainians
to return back to their homes
whatever what we need for now to do this
of course to ensure security
to uphold freedom and Justice and to
Foster adenomic economy recovery
yet we recognize that we are not able
and can't achieve it alone
we actually seek for strategic
partnership
that can serve as a catalyst for
investment to Ukraine
we invite ukrainians to return home and
the global Community to join our
transformative Journey
investing in our resilient Nation
and sharing in its prosperity
this is more than a national task it's
our Global call to action demonstrating
that democracy and freedom to move over
the deleterism and Corruption so thank
you and Slava to Ukraine
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed and for
setting out your vision for Ukraine and
making clear that
um you can't do it alone that you're
going to need strategic Partnerships and
and that's what we're going to be
talking about
um now we've got
um I think coming any minute
um are
um
uh
business secretary but just perhaps
while we wait for her to arrive if we
could start by going
um straight on we're looking at the
international financial institutions
today to take a lead and so I'm
delighted to introduce uh next the
president of the European bank for
reconstruction and development odile
Reno basso to set out the priorities in
the long and the short term for
Ukraine's recovery thank you thank you
very much and I'm very happy to be here
and and to give the point of view of a
bank which mandate I mean has been
created in a way to help Ukraine
transformation since the independence in
1991 and we we've been the first
International in the Institutional
Investor in the country invested more
than 18 billion so I will talk from this
perspective and also how we see what we
are doing now what we can do now and how
what we see as a challenge and
opportunities ahead
I think what I want to underline from my
gospel personal and the bank experience
is a resilience of Ukraine it's amazing
to see I've been traveling to Kev twice
in the last year to see the resilience
of the people the way they handle the
situation I mean with a very very calm
and determination and resolve you know I
mean really and also the the residents
of the economy and I think that after
the big shock of the war and and the
fact that Allah I mean part of the
territory which was engine for wars in
the country is under I mean heavy fight
or occupied till now the economy
stabilized slightly positive growth even
so I mean the resilience look at the
fact that economy still functioning the
banking system is in functioning banks
have open nothing has been
suspended this is a very strong
strands and and I think that we can
build on this resilience to develop
invest investment
based on this diagnosing what is my
message today is that we are very much
open for business so we are doing we
decided very quickly after a bit of you
know the shock of the of the war very
early on we decided to continue to
invest in the country and to continue to
support both key infrastructure we
shifted a bit our activity in order to
because the priority was at some point
of time to support key infrastructure
electricity Network Railway network
access to gas but also continue working
with the private sector through the
banking system and directly and also
with strike Finance so with continuing
to do that we as we get them doing a
support and share all the support and I
want to thank all countries including
the UK Germany and so forth who help us
to share the risk because of course for
the bank it's it's a challenge but I
think now I mean this worked very well
and we see a lot of Demands of needs and
of opportunities
overall since the beginning of the war
we have invested 2.5 billion our
objective is by the end of the year to
have invested at least 3 billion and and
we see only flows of project and and we
have I mean there is a really important
needs
um as I was saying our objective was
really easy to support the real economy
not the budget support there have been a
lot of International Community has
provided a lot of budget support which
is key also to sustain I mean for the
government to continue to function
people to have I mean civil servants to
be paid the people to receive their
pension but supporting the real economy
and access to electricity to heating to
transport and so forth is also very
important for the economy to continue
going for the government it will provide
tax revenues for the government and so
forth so I think it's very much part of
the short-term response and and it's
there I mean echoing the notion of
resilience it's amazing how all these
key infrastructure I've been adjusting
to the challenges created by the war
under destruction and the repeated
destruction with the Russian bombing
so I think moving forward in order to be
equipped to be able to enhance I mean to
sustain our investment in Ukraine and to
enhance we are now discussing with our
travel to some Capital increase so this
will give you a small margin of maneuver
and and capacity to plan also and we
want really to focus on the construction
ebrd you know the or individuald is
reconstruction and we really want to be
to live up to our name and and focusing
on on reconstruction
as Deputy Prime Minister was saying the
country has a huge potential huge assets
in be it in agribusiness manufacturing
capabilities I.T sector strong financial
sector who has been very resilient in
the war but also well-trained Human
Resources
proximity to the New Market the
perspective of joining the EU which is
and we've heard this morning the
commission president of the commission
meant a very strong determination that
this will move forward quickly and the
strong political political commitment to
move on in that direction I think all
these are very important elements Paving
the way for for reconstruction and what
we are trying to our the way we try to
contribute to that is to um
develop an ecosystem of solutions so
there is one no wondrous response one
single way to do that to contribute but
I think there is many things that we can
do in order to facilitate the
Reconstruction this includes mobilizing
private financing domestic
but also foreign to support investment
and to invest
um and and we are ready to accompany
this investment the second element is to
improve improve improve absorption
capacity at the national level at the
regional level a local government there
are a lot of things that work that can
be done with municipalities
strengthening institutions and
supporting reforms through the path of
EU integration and let me focus on on
the number of initiative we we are happy
to announce today or we've been
developing
the first one is cooperation to work I
mean together and we've just signed and
whether an mou with a national
development financial institution
working all in the private sector in
order to create a sort of drone platform
for financing project in the private
sector bringing our Pipeline and being a
sort of single entry point avoiding
multiple you know
ecdfi going for its own assessment of
the project due diligence and so forth
so joining forces and and we signed an
mou and this will be I think a very
effective way to coordinate we managed
to it shows I think the determination
and the commitment to support Ukraine
because we managed to show in a record
period of time with 19 DFI so we are
very very happy with that second key
issue is and it's been discussed very a
lot this morning is the risking
instruments and um more insurance and so
forth there is a lot of things already
existing meager has been having this
kind of instrument uh I mean it was
created for that but you also have
National
um guarantee instrument some countries
mentioned that this morning what we are
trying to do is to bring back a private
sector insurance
and in order building a sort of
framework there are also a pilot project
where we will bring back private
insurance and reinsurance
with providing some support financing in
order to relaunch the market and to
start with we Our intention is to focus
on the trade facilitation because there
is I mean Insurance are either
non-existing or very costly in terms of
Transportation good transportation and
so forth and we think it's useful to
start with but at a small scale but to
see and to build up from there so this
is what we call the Ukraine recovery
guarantee facility which aims to
leverage donor grants with EU guarantees
to mitigate all of the risk on trade so
the priority and so I mean key issue is
increase absorption capacity and improve
the project delivery capacity and and we
want to work jointly with World bank and
eib to develop a capacity daily project
preparation capacity support
and the last point which I think is is
very important also for the long-term
investment Prospect is the reform agenda
and
good governance
favorable business environment
transparent tax framework strong
institution rule of flow continued fight
against corruption these are very
important elements which we deserve a
full attention and it's very good to see
the government so committed to continue
to deliver on that agenda despite the
challenging environment because this is
a fundamental element for trust and to
attract investment we are playing every
part in that with recovery from
architecture which brings experts to
continue to deliver on that but this
will be key in order to for Ukraine to
build back better be more green stronger
and extremely attractive in terms of
foreign investment so I'm very confident
very happy but there is of course a lot
of work to do and to do together thank
you
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed and I think
we can welcome at this point
um the UK Secretary of State for the
Department of Business and trade who can
perhaps respond to um
uh first of all adapted prime minister's
Vision over the over the next 10 years
and and you talked about the European
standards and I think we've heard some
of those um but it would be it would be
great to hear about the UK's view as
strategic Partnerships thank you very
much uh Sarah and thank you everyone for
being at this plenary today and in
particular I'm really happy to be
sitting here next to my friend either
who we've had multiple interactions with
not uh least of all the recent uh
digital free trade agreements which uh
which we signed together
I think broadly if we take a step back
and look at what it is we're trying to
do uh you know given the conversations
that we've had we want to make sure that
uh Ukraine is in a better place than it
was before this War Began we don't want
uh the country certainly the Ukrainian
government doesn't want the country to
just pick up where it left off let alone
uh further back and trying to make sure
that we Corral all of the right
resources in order for people to think
about that vision of the future what
Ukraine could look like is the story
that we want to tell and that That's the
basis of the sport which we are are
giving and we cannot underestimate the
size of the task that is uh that is
ahead of us speaking specifically from
my Department's perspective I think one
of the things that we really want to
emphasize is how this is not
government's job and just looking at the
people who are in the room who are
attending the conference it shows that
everybody recognizes that they have a
part to play this is something that's
going to require quite a lot of help
efforts infrastructure from the private
private sector and uh I think the figure
that I've been given in terms of the
size of what would be needed will be
about 411 billion according to World
Bank figures I mean that is that's
phenomenal where are we going to get
those resources from so emphasizing the
need for private sector involvement in
Ukraine's recovery given the sale of the
scale of the cost is one of the jobs
that I have so that people know exactly
what it is that we're trying to what it
is we're trying to do and there is a
huge amount of Goodwill so far we've
seen so much hundreds of businesses have
signed the business Compact and I wanted
to welcome support such as a corporate
twinning program from fresh Fields
already underway there's ongoing
planning for a care of international
finance Center by Consortium led by the
lse and you know just wanted to say
thank you so much for for all that work
so ongoing support is critical to make
sure that we don't uh the things don't
get worse and then we can also think
about what the future will hold so areas
like energy are particularly important
so my department has been working not
just across the UK government but
actually with other governments on
things like emergency emergency repairs
that were required to main maintain
power supplies over the winter and the
key the key to success is making sure
that we do that well but also set set
things up as we're doing that for the
large-scale future reconstruction the
subsequent growth and full participation
in a modern sustainable economy once
Ukraine has won the conflict so I if I
look at other areas where we've been
able to to collaborate the last meeting
we had we talked about the importance of
technology to to Ukraine's recovery so
we are here to support and help meet uh
meet those Ambitions uh the UK request
National Recovery plans focus is on
resilience and we know that when we talk
about the infrastructure we think about
the things that you can see but actually
there is a tech sector Powerhouse in the
country we hire a lot of people from
Ukraine even now yesterday I met lots of
businesses who talked about the
Ukrainian employees which they had all
around the world really uh inspiring
them to make sure that they took part in
the uh in the recovery efforts and to
2022 amazingly was a record year for
Ukraine's Tech sector there was still
seven and a half billion pounds in
export volume which Grew From three 3.2
billion in 2018. so I want to make sure
that when we're talking about this we're
also emphasize the success that is still
taking place despite the conflict and
despite uh the share scale of activity
that um that you're you're having to
deal with you again so we are supporting
the tech sector the digital Trade
Agreement which I referenced earlier
today uh was also referenced earlier in
this session was one of the things that
the UK is trying to do with other
countries we've only done it once with
Singapore so this is an example of our
sleep frogging a digital Trade Agreement
is very different from what people are
used to hearing or sign people think
about trade agreements as just being
exports and their visualized containers
but what we signed uh together was
things like data localization making it
easier to transfer information between
the two countries so I think that there
is a lot of good work that we will see
utilizing that Free Trade Agreement and
I wanted to also emphasize that we
launched the business Bridge uh Ukraine
platform so that helps businesses
identify and link up with counterparts
who provide the kind of service for
their business needs and there are a few
other government initiatives which I
think we've been announcing throughout
this conference we connected businesses
to Priority projects we've produced a
guide to doing business with Ukraine
that's one of the things that my
department did and what we're really
trying to do is show International
Leadership we think that we have a role
to play In Shining a light on what
everyone else can do UK can do that very
very well and we're working with
multilaterals a deal has been talking
about the work that she's doing working
with multilaterals with other
governments to highlight emphasize and
provide as much support not just to the
Ukrainian people but also to the
government to ensure that we end up in a
much better place than where we started
thank you
thank you very much indeed
it's perfect here Ukraine is the as the
tech sector Powerhouse and that sense of
leapfrogging that that you mentioned
um and just that every what everyone can
do if if it's um if people are
galvanized and we heard
um earlier today from Germany about
particularly about how it's rising and
to the challenge of humanitarian Aid
particularly for those displaced but
we're now going to hear from uh svenger
schultzer who is Minister for economic
cooperation and development of Germany
on Germany's um contribution
yeah first of all I would like to on the
line on what really about what kemi said
that that is an immense task for
generations to rebuild Ukraine and we
need to be aware of that that we need
everybody on board we need different
actors we need a smart a
well-coordinated approach and it is
easier to say than to deliver so that is
our common task here together and it is
important that we ensure that we now the
right course that we said now the right
priorities
um that needs to be achieved by all
Partners it's not finger pointing on
each others we need to work together
here to help Ukraine to to be on the
buildback better as it was announced
before so it is not enough that we have
the public sector on board we need
private engagement we need the private
sector and you know that
driving local companies they create jobs
they increase tax revenue that's needed
so they attract further investment they
lead in and
stainability and that is what we also
want to reach and a healthy National
economy is really an important factor
for successful recovery and for
resilient Society
um creating the right conditions for
that that is what we are discussing here
about and that is what is needed and
that is where Germany is helping Ukraine
on on that way and let me provide just a
few concrete examples and many companies
in Ukraine have been impacted by the war
for example due to a disrupted Supply
chains or of because of loss of scale
markets and our Echo economic operation
and development programs work closely
with Ukraine Ukrainian companies to
continue operating in times of War for
example by advising an alternative
supply chain and alternative location
for example like connecting Ukraine's at
companies with business opportunities or
by closing Supply gaps through our
financing and it is really obvious that
Investments required uh requires
suitable framework conditions and these
are closely linked to a successful
reform reform and an EU session
protesters you'll have mentioned that
before how important are that is and
Germany's business never left Ukraine
and I'm really grateful and impressed
that the company stayed even during a
desirable at times of war and we now see
an increasing interest in Ukraine as an
investment destination and the German
business Community is making specific
contributions to meet acute needs and
the energy and the construction in the
house and the seat sectors and Germany's
investment and Export credits guarantees
enable German Enterprises to operate in
Ukraine and with Ukrainian companies
um
to further facilitate a private sector
involvement it is up to Ukraine to gain
the trust of the business Community you
mentioned it um it is crucial that the
conducive environment is created for
foreign direct investment and for the
Ukraine economy and that means
comprehensive reforms anti-corruption
measures are transparent tendering
procedures legal certainty uh as all of
as a part of a broader Pathway to Europe
and Germany also supports Ukraine on on
this way providing government advisory
services and by strengthening Ukrainian
administer administrative bodies and at
both on National and and Municipal level
it's also important to look at the
municipal on the local level because
that is also important you just
mentioned in the the session sales
status we support Ukraine on the way in
the EU we do that over years and we'll
continue to do so and you see how much
progress is done during the time of war
that is amazing in such times that your
Ukraine makes such steps forward and I
would like to highlight recovery and
reconstruction go beyond materially
rebuilding a damaged infrastructure let
us build Bridges from humanitarian Aid
that is needed now to reconstruction to
long-term sustainable recovery that
means also social cohesion the promotion
of social protect participation
um inclusive inclusivity are a key
factors for success in in this regard
and Germany is also providing
comprehensive support in that since
February last year Germany has created
as much as 3.6 billion euros in total
for civil support in Ukraine and that is
just one part of the German humanitarian
development military and civil support
and the amount of around
16.8 billion euros and we want to help
the Ukrainian people to cope with
displacement the social economic effects
of the Russian war of aggression aren't
the psychological needs of families of
children and public services need to be
could continue then that is also a part
of where we are helping so it is
important that the European government
and the International Community not only
secure funding and economic investment
but also ensure that reconstruct and
Recovery efforts adhere to the luganum
principles as we agreed in Switzerland
last year this includes an inclusive and
transparent a sustainable and reform
oriented process and that is driven by
the Ukrainian people it's not driven by
us it's driven by the Ukrainian people
and this also means that reconstruction
must be carbon neutral it must be
resilient and all the things we agreed
on it is easier to say that than to
deliver I know but together we must
strive for a free and European future
for Ukraine Ukraine's resilient society
that deseriffs are our full respect and
our full support and we stand ready to
continue our assistance and
collaboration with our Ukrainian
Partners at all levels of government on
Administration as well as with the
Ukrainian strong civil society and let
us also engage them we need on the one
hand the all the companies the private
sector but we also need to to bring
together the Civil Society and bring
them on board so thank you very much for
your attention and I'm looking for to
work together
thank you very much indeed thanks for
reminding us of the megano principles
and uh also just what those can
conditions need to be for transformation
uh our next speaker
um head of the international finance
cooperation and formerly the world
bank's vice president for infrastructure
so he understands transformation above
all and can tell us how this applies to
Ukraine please welcome macto Delp head
of the international finance cooperation
thank you so very much it's a pleasure
to be here let me just say a few words
about what the IFC is IFC is the urban
group has three components which is
migas has been mentioned already by Audi
which is with the guarantee we are the
ibrd which is doing the finance and I
believe that my colleague and abjadi was
one of the panel and you have the IFC
which is a leading
investors from dfis in emerging
economies so for me what I want to say
first is the timeliness of the
conference so why is the conference now
and I think it's very timely so first
attack the first phase we had to do and
I would like to commence Minister
because we've been in many meetings
talking about recovery assessment the
first phase was to to keep the country
alive and I think it was totally normal
that at times there were a larger flow
of public resources to keep the budget
running to pass every servant to support
the world effort that was a critical and
necessary condition to be able to think
about the the next step and so what I've
been doing an excellent job in
mobilizing those resources I think that
looking at it I think the world realize
that now once one now that Ukraine not
only has been able to to protect his
line but now is regaining the land that
they have lost it's time to think more
more aggressively about reconstruction
and I think this is very important that
we as a conference and now on today so
so what what I think that will be is
interesting is that during the the time
where the government was thinking about
the the protecting the nation at the
same time they didn't waste time they
invested in looking at the regulatory
Frameworks that we're allowed to crowd
in private sector I remember having
conversation with with uh with the
Ukrainian counterparts and they were
telling me that they were working on the
law on competition and different laws to
be able to pave the way for the new
phase that we're entering in that
context we were asked a tasked to be
leading the PPP
advisory and for us it's very important
because the public private partnership
framework and pipeline design that will
be will be Paving the way for all these
Investments that we need to to have it
so first first request all these
investors that were here we have my team
lead here by Alfonso who is the vice
president please go to him and talk to
him about business opportunities that's
why he's four so let's make it very
concrete so that the time we are
spending here is used to do do this
during that period of of keeping the
country uh you know on the street we
invested the best task was to keep the
money flowing so we invested in and
helped on trade financing and that will
continue doing that because we need to
continue importing and exporting and we
asked our bigger not only to bring that
guarantee to us but to extend it to
everybody we need that that's what will
happen the second one was to continue
the flow of resources to our clients
which were in Ukraine and to be able to
to to to to to allow them to to continue
these activities so we did it without
any guarantee we use our balance sheet
expose it and we said we have to to
financial companies in the agricultural
sector in the tech sector in the trade
sector in the banking sector so they can
continue functioning and supporting the
government now this phase that we're
entering is a phase of articulating
about a reconstruction program to
billion dollars where we will continue
investing in various sectors let me tell
you a couple of the sectors I've been
investing already yeah here on my right
we have one of our clients Because he
believes that Tech is a is a we need to
to work on the with Ukraine because the
tech potential is known so we continue
uh investing in that sector we work with
with great client but also we are
investing in other companies to be able
to keep the infrastructure in Telecom so
Tech will be an important area
investment secondly agriculture we have
investing in some agriculture areas and
some investors and we mobilize investors
from France for other countries we
invested in a in a in in Ukraine and we
are seeing the impact third is logistics
because we believe that without
Logistics the country will not be able
to to respond to the to the needs and we
are currently for instance advising uh
we'll be starting actually design
signing today an agreement advise a
company on the logistics side but also
support the the sea transport that will
be necessary so what we're hearing from
from our our clients from the private
sector they need equity
and when we whenever we talk to
investors in Ukraine they tell us it's
good to have loans it's good to have it
but Equity is even better so we have
done something we have lowered and not
lower but we have changed and adapted
our risk profile and our our procedure
to be able to meet some of this
requirements because if you apply the
traditional way of looking at risk we
will never we should we will not be able
to invest in equity in in Ukraine but
what the companies are telling us is
that we need Equity Equity Equity uh so
this is something that we're looking at
and we try to mobilize more more people
to do that secondly we need to to repeat
the country in a green way and I think
that we have great opportunities here to
do it actually in ifcs this year 47 of
our Landing will be climate related so
it has been one of our important focus
and we're seeing a few opportunities
Minister mentioned is a sector of a of a
methodology aluminum and so forth we
believe that the hard to Abate sectors
as we call them in our garden are
sectors that will require a lot of our
support and we will be working very
closely with investors in this area why
because it's usually the sectors that
are not looked at people are investing
more in in a generation of green
electricity but not enough in helping
the aluminum sector the industrial
sector to have a much less carbon
content in their production if you don't
want to rebate a Ukraine different from
what what you can used to be it will be
a Ukraine which have a manufacturing
sector with a much lower content on
carbon because it was a very intensive
carbon production so how we work with
the companies to help them on that path
will be will be a second priority but
but let's not forget some things that we
cannot do that without also being an
inclusive Society for us gender will be
an important part of what we are doing
if we don't ensure that all women in
Ukraine we have shown the residence and
the leadership that they're showing
today are not included as they should be
included in the productive sector and we
are lucky to have great example we will
not be able to to to to help the
government of Ukraine with our
interventions and private sector to
build the society such as the aspiring
to to to to to apply so these are a few
elements of what at IFC we will be we
will be doing and we will be doing it by
by trying to uh the risk also some of
the investment and I I will not I will
be making a big mistake if I don't think
thank some of our partners who have
provided us with granted money uh
Netherlands Switzerland the the UK and
the European commission uh uh and Bri
and we are supporting us with providing
us a grant money which help us today
with some of our investment but the most
uh the more we get uh of grandma is the
more we can invest in equity the more we
can take risk and the more we can help
the government of Ukraine to move in the
directions so I will stop here because I
know that we are running out of time but
I just wanted to say that it's a very
timely uh conference and we hope that
there will be a mechanism to follow up
on the implementation of what has been
discussed today so that all of us who
are here can be accountable of what we
are committed for thank you
[Applause]
hoping that as you say this is a this is
timely and it's a call for investors and
investment now
um and uh
we're talking of investment our next uh
speaker
um Lena kazani CEO of horizon capital a
leading U.S private Equity Firm that has
raised the largest fund for Ukraine
since the invasion it was also the first
so it'd be interesting to hear the
benefits of first mover and about risks
and about resilience thank you very much
thank you so much it's such a pleasure
to be here at the same time I feel an
incredible responsibility on my
shoulders representing the private
sector and we've heard so much about the
importance of engaging the private
sector today so first I want to set the
context I've lived 30 years in Ukraine
Ukraine is my home
and we've raised 1.4 billion over the
years invested a billion and through the
funds that we've managed we have
employed 77 000 people in over 160
companies and today on the ground
through the equity that we've provided
to our partners and often we're the only
investor alongside the founders we have
26 000 people across the country who are
providing essential Services who are in
e-commerce in retail in Tech in consumer
companies which we see are contributing
to the resilience that we see on the
ground in the country so I'm very
passionate about this I'm very
passionate about the private sector
being engaged and I'll start with this
with today we heard from President
zielinski we heard about Vision
agreements and real projects
and for us I mean when we put out the
vision of 250 million dollar fund raised
during the time of War to give Equity
growth equity
to entrepreneurs right now not when the
war is over when we had that vision of
course that was before the war the
full-fledged Invasion we were on track
to pull that off in March 2022
and of course we took a pause but to
focus on safety security on business
models on the companies on all the
people that I've talked about but I have
to say when we restarted in May
it's because of the folks sitting beside
me it's because of maktar and I've seen
Adil and ebrd Western and as DG fmo
Rockefeller Foundation others see Femme
who backed us at our first closing by
September we had 125 Million by April we
had brought together in addition to I've
seen ebrd eight governments eight dfis
that are governed that from countries
from U.S DFC from Sweden so that fund
Finn fund I already mentioned fmodg ifu
from Denmark
we had brought all of those together and
exceeded our Target in April so in April
28th we exceeded our 250 million Target
and now we're investing we're not only
talking about investing but in fact
we've closed the transaction we will
close two more in the next quarter and
we are putting that money to work now in
Ukraine in the private sector with
entrepreneurs who have
a great deal of difficulty raising
Capital elsewhere I just want you to
appreciate the magnitude of the problem
here imagine if you're an entrepreneur
and you can barely attract a loan at 25
you're lucky if you get a local currency
loan at 25 percent
Equity is almost undreamable if you are
a tech company if you're an expert
oriented company
you are being told quietly if you move
your people out of Ukraine or if you
fire your Ukrainian team we'll give you
Capital we're staying the opposite and
that's what we should all be saying
build your business in Ukraine expand
your footprint add jobs add make sure
that you're investing in a gender Smart
Way
and make sure that you've got
you know 50 50 women and men on your
teams I mean that's what we're saying to
our companies that we're investing in
right now so so I guess my my message
first and foremost is this is that
we had the vision thanks to all these
wonderful institutions and I can't even
tell you the outside role that iberdeen
obviously playing in Ukraine and I hope
that everyone who has they've asked for
Grants or backing has filled their
coffers because we need them and we need
their coffers to be full in Ukraine they
are the first the folks are going to and
then the second thing is I hope that all
countries who have
a development Finance institution have
ensured that they have a mandate for
Ukraine we're we're seeing that happen
over the Sierra some are there some are
not but everyone should have their
mandates open for Ukraine already
and in terms of the private sector look
these are the folks that are driving
resilience I can't tell you enough I
could spend the whole day telling you
about amazing stories about people on
the ground I'm going to share three very
quickly I know I'm but I want to to
leave these with you I want to share the
story of
in February 2022 Sasha Clinton won
Forbes entrepreneur of the year he leads
Ajax systems which is the ring of
Ukraine
when the full-fledged Invasion happened
he moved 160 20 ton trucks of production
equipment to safer location in April he
was already four times daily output back
on track producing and it opened up a
platform on Saturday Ukraine as well
I look at Aurora which is like a
discount retailer that was present
through South and Eastern Ukraine
863 stores before the full-fledged
Invasion dropped to 636
they're at 970 stores they're opening a
store every 17 hours why because they
know that the communities that they are
operating in need those stores they need
that access to Goods they're
prioritizing South East the the occupied
territories
and the last thing I I was so impressed
by what prime minister
um of the UK Rishi sunak said today
about this this profound hope about the
soldier who planted seeds
knowing that those homeowners will come
back and maybe they will have given root
you know
when cassan was occupied we had we we've
invested in one of the largest Broadband
cable companies they are number one
across the country fiber optic cable
we had 50 people in the cup song we were
dismayed when we saw the images of
occupiers coming into the offices you
know ripping cables out of the wall
stealing equipment breaking everything
we had 18 people who remained during
occupation imagine during the entire
Persona occupation we continue to pay
the South continued to make sure that
they were paid in their Ukrainian
accounts in in non-occupied territory
but the day of liberation
when the CEO of this company
called those 18 people
he was in shock because one person the
person who was responsible for all the
equipment the CTO had hid the most
important piece of equipment under his
bed
for the entire occupation hid a hundred
and fifty thousand dollar Cisco piece of
equipment under his bed
that's why we need to liberate these
territories that is what people are
risking and that is what the private
sector is doing and that enabled
connectivity within 24 hours in Hassan
back to Prior sector
give ukrainians the resources to help
themselves thank you
thank you for that really exhilarating
um expression of the Defiance of the
spirit of defiance and build your own
business in Ukraine I think is the
message absolutely for today
um and part of the answer is going to be
to to scale is to create fun vehicles
that um appeal to a wider group of
investors listed fund vehicles are a
recognized way of doing this so what
interest is the London Stock Exchange
seeing from fund managers and investors
more broadly around this kind of
opportunities and what can the London
Stock Exchange do to support it well
luckily we have with us um David
Schwimmer the CEO of London Stock
Exchange to address these questions well
thank you Sarah and Lynn and thank you
for uh those rousing remarks and I just
want to pick up on that and acknowledge
the extraordinary resilience of the
Ukrainian people
and uh what they have done to keep the
economy going among other things we are
an international company London Stock
Exchange group elsig and we have people
in Ukraine we have customers in Ukraine
uh we had a team in Russia we had a
business in Russia we shut that down we
uh last year suspended the Securities
trading on the London Stock Exchange
from Russia we
expelled the Securities listed in our
index business in the ftse Russell index
business and our world check database
which is the leading database around the
world for kyc and AML and sanctions data
was used by customers all over the world
to respond to
uh to the sanctions that were imposed
and today we're very proud to join this
group to join the recovery conference we
hosted a market open this morning with
the chancellor with a number of other
members of the financial ecosystem here
last night we hosted an event
emphasizing the critical role of female
leaders in maintaining the Ukrainian or
Ukrainian economy I acknowledged your
comments about really focusing on that
opportunity in these times as well but
these events highlight the importance of
public markets as well machiar commented
on Equity Equity Equity you have spoken
about the opportunity and the need with
private equity
the public markets play a critical role
here and the public markets can play
that role with respect to both public
Equity but also with respect to debt
financing
and I think given the scale of the
challenge this is not something that
governments can do on their own this is
not something that ngos can do on their
own we absolutely need a private sector
Capital debt and Equity Finance involved
I think in addition to the public
Capital raising created by a listing
environment
a listing also creates a profile it
attracts Talent it becomes a currency
and it's a critical element in terms of
the role for public markets in terms of
helping Ukraine both secure its
infrastructure but build the dynamic
Innovative and sustainable economy that
we have been hearing about this morning
uh when Stock Exchange group owns the
London Stock Exchange and lse is the
world's most International Exchange
where we ex we attract investors who
understand risk who are comfortable
taking a long-term perspective
and who are comfortable driving
improvement in governance standards
now prior to last year's large-scale
Invasion we already had a very active
involvement with Ukrainian companies
with Ukrainian economy having had nine
companies currently listed on the stock
exchange from Ukraine and a similar
number of bonds from Ukrainian entities
and we are looking forward to continuing
to play that role in partnership with
Ukraine in partnership with the markets
in Kiev we are currently engaging in the
proposed International Financial Center
discussions in Kiev to have that entity
join the major cities as part of the
world Alliance of International
Financial Centers we are also in
discussions with Ukraine's National
Securities and stock market Commission
in terms of capacity building in terms
of support for local Capital markets in
Ukraine and in due course for dual
listings listings in Ukraine that are
also listed here in London where we can
provide that access to domestic capital
and to International capital
I am proud to announce today uh in in
our modest way uh our efforts to help
uh that over the next uh over the coming
year the London Stock Exchange will
waive listing fees uh for Equity issues
by Ukrainian businesses and we will also
be waiving admission fees for fixed
income issuances that are guaranteed by
the Ukrainian government
okay
and so in in that context we look
forward both as soon as possible but
also on an ongoing basis to help play a
role in bringing Capital into the public
markets to help with the recovery of
Ukraine and uh really the the very
impressive Vision that has been laid out
in terms of what will be built in in the
Ukrainian economy going forward
the uh
people of Ukraine including our people
in Ukraine I'm very proud to have seen
how they have helped continue to serve
our customers in Ukraine and how they
have continued to Pride provide data and
keep the markets running in Ukraine and
I would say there's that kind of
resilience that kind of opportunity that
they have continued to maintain and
those kinds of services that they have
continued to provide I think it's an
example of the critical role that
Capital markets play
uh and I hope that we can build on their
courageous efforts to create a stronger
brighter future for the people of
Ukraine thank you
thank you very much
um and we we've heard a lot today about
um Ukraine's defense of European values
um and accession actually to um to the
um and those standards that uh you're
showing and the reforms that you're
undertaking and so we're going to hear
now from
um Marissa bachopnik Barrick as
Secretary General Council of Europe the
Council of Europe has produced in
consultation an action plan for Ukraine
called resilience recovery and
reconstruction which seeks to support
standards in human rights the rule of
law and democracy in line with the
European Union values so over to you
first of all thank you very much Sarah
thank you to the UK government to have
organized such an event very timely and
very good well targeted and at least I'm
not aware of another event that has such
a variety of stakeholders and in a view
of huge needs so it was mentioned
earlier I think we really need to
coordinate cooperate or
look for opportunities where people can
do more or together or or everyone in
its part and I liked very much your
minister when you say that there is a
transformative Journey for Ukraine and
what we do is very much actually
accompanying Ukraine on this very
important very challenging very
difficult Journey
but I think we are well placed to work
on our background on what all what you
said before you are doing that actually
we are rule of law democracy and human
rights organization and I think in
respect of business environment and and
having uh when the pins comes and it
will come
but still now working on rule of law I
think it's very crucial for securing uh
all those who are investing have been
investing and think of investing in in
Ukraine so uh but let me start with with
the beginning
there was the the
LSC uh said that they shut down the
business in in Russia actually we are
the only International Organization who
excluded Russia from its membership and
almost from the day one
and uh
you know on the very morning on the 24th
of February last year it was very clear
for us the the Russia was breaching uh
basic rules and statutes and values we
stand for so it took just a few days one
day to suspend and then procedurally
another 10 to to 14 days to exclude
Russia so that was very much how we
thought we have to react and from the
day one we were actually with our
members member states Ukraine shoulder
to shoulder trying to adjust immediately
what we can do and what we did
immediately was the action plan that was
ongoing we actually adapted to the
situation there was a need to Pro for
for helping prosecutor General in
investigating uh alleged and and
obviously happening uh human gross human
rights violations but also we continued
to work on reforms and this is I think
what is really Commander greatly
commendable and admirable in Ukraine
that even in at all times during this
horrible War
the government was dedicated to reforms
and dedicated to the Future and at the
same time fighting fighting the horrible
war of aggression that they were exposed
and that made me think I in my career I
work a lot in
in the countries that needed reform and
I work also in private sector I was
saying the company was listed in London
Stock Exchange and actually you know the
CEO was saying you know how to run and
and compete with the with the best
companies in the world listed on the LSC
and at the same time transform reform
and compete so sometimes I feel this is
where Ukraine actually is now and I
think we helping Ukraine on that very
important transformative journey is is
important but you mentioned the Action
Plan before that I will mention
something else which is important for
peace to to uh to be just unsustainable
which is accountability we just recently
had their only food Summit in a long
history of the Council of European
Reykjavik and our leaders decided to to
form a register it was mentioned by
prime minister schmichael and it was
reflected also in the second panel uh
when the register of damage of
infrastructure damage
was mentioned that it will join our
register so our register is about
victim-centered support and having a
place where people who suffered
loss and damage civil or moral or or
material can deposit their claims
because this is also how do we know what
we what uh it's owed to Russia to to to
to Ukraine if we know don't know what
the the claims are so uh I'm convening
next week uh the 42 hopefully soon 45 uh
State parties
all states from three continent all G7
members
almost all Council of Europe members we
are we reached to three continents I
hope with today's conference that we are
reaching to to Africa as well and and
with this I would like to say that
register is open to everyone who is
like-minded who want to support this uh
this uh
victim-centered approach and the the
register will be based in The Hague and
with an antenna in in queue so this is
about accountability I think that is
important for the piece for the action
plan that we have on resilience recovery
and reconstruction actually indeed it
has a part which deals with how to
restore re um
how to work with the reform of Judiciary
how to uh also reform constitutional
Court in a way that is compliance with
the European standards and what we are
doing actually is all also important in
in at least two other ways one is in
general we talk about business
opportunities Investments which will
bring Prosperity but in general you know
rule of law
combating corruption is good for each
and every citizen in every aspect of
life they live so we are we are we are
working at that and I I'm glad that at
each of the of the discussion
anti-corruption was mentioned we are
also working on on economic crime in
general which is very important for
investment as you well know so on me
media reform on on reforms that are
actually making Ukraine stronger
democracy a stronger rule of law uh
country and in that way actually more
apt for uh for the future that we all I
think were trying to describe how we
will uh how we will add other parts to
it and I think there is a lot to do from
all of our parts so indeed our action
plan is mentioned for four years it's
the biggest action plan that we have in
in different member states but I think
the work we do really support what we
want the Ukraine to have which is a lot
of investment a lot more businesses
someone was saying all what is what is
to to be done is also to attract
ukrainians who are for obvious Reason
Not in Ukraine to come back and I think
that's crucial because you need people
to uh to to to to Really move the
country forward so I think what we are
doing at the Council of Europe with our
action plan helps uh business
environment conducive for investment but
actually helps Ukraine in general and I
think and that was uh what I take from
all three panels and I'm happy one to be
the last one I think we all agree that
we can do more and that we should need
more and I'm I'm glad for the register
that you proposed which will actually
list what we were saying now and then
see whether we follow walk the talk and
I think if we do so uh we and we if we
do it together we will prevail and
Ukraine will very soon get where it
wants to be a modern and developed
European uh country thank you very much
thank you very much indeed you've heard
some uh diverse perspectives and common
purpose I'd like to come back if I may
to um can we bad knock our secretary of
state for business and trade for your
Reflections and and perhaps your hopes
for the um outcomes of this conference
uh well I think my Reflections are just
how much uh in sympathy we all are in
terms of what it is we're trying to
achieve I think what I really hope is
that Julia can take a lot of reassurance
and encouragement from all of the things
that uh the panel uh the panelists have
been saying throughout this plenary
session we we are committed we are going
to put resources in we have lots of uh
bright ideas I think you know the story
that Lena was talking about just showing
how that the mindset of of ukrainians
you are actually inspiring us to do to
do so much and and the more of that that
we see I think the more people will come
together to uh to help support the
reconstruction effort the recovery
effort and this this plenary session I
think is one which should be giving hope
not just to you but across the
government so I'm really pleased that
we've been able to put this on and hope
I've left you feeling very optimistic as
well as everyone in the room and all the
participants as well
you very much indeed invest invest
invest and that's the end of the session
but thank you very much indeed
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that's me
no a little
I don't know I'm not sure
of course
respond
s to check those two names hello
um
everything's balanced and all wrapped
and cold yeah
from which
so like what should you want me to go
and give you a Lexus shot yeah
you're doing it I do okay
I want to make sure that it's Square on
top
a little bit
yes
it seems good to meet you
yeah
I just need to go and find Neil and then
you always been here
I'm gonna
say she's the owner
well
um
give me this morning
so really then
because
okay English English I'm speaking
English can you hear me right yeah
English English and English Channel
foreign
all right
oh okay
and you like
like yeah no I know
foreign
check all right
Hi how are you
foreign
you've got everything
I'm gonna be moving
well um
it's actually the same thing it's only
here
like
I don't think like anyone will pass here
it's the only way in for those guys
foreign
thank you
my I have a friend day with
words
foreign
I don't know
ladies and gentlemen thank you and
welcome in the panel both posters for a
sector and the vice prime minister they
are expected to arrive in about five
seven minutes thank you very much for
your patience and we'll start during the
next day
um
foreign
everybody
we agree with you as the reference to
the beginning
transparency session is due to start
please start taking your seats the
transparency session it will start
shortly please take your seats thank you
all right
foreign
people commissions
thank you
okay yeah
foreign
good
Ness
happy wife
two
and two
I can't hear that yeah
the one that's why
number nine seconds
great
of course
Maybe
foreign
[Music]
thank you for coming
um let's get to it so we have a
fantastic panel with you less very Danko
first Deputy Prime Minister of Ukraine
James cleverly UK Secretary of State for
foreign Commonwealth and development
Affairs I'm Garrett young cookman
director general for neighborhood and
enlargement negotiations European
Commission
Stephanie Von Friedberg senior managing
director at Citibank cement crevonos
director of the nationality corruption
Bureau of Ukraine and Victor nestulia
chair rice Coalition of Ukrainian CEOs
um and we'll start with Julius verdeck
opening remarks thank you very much
of course you can I mean you you do you
know you can yes
I think that I damaged something
everything
um
so first of all I would like to start
with a statement that
no doubt that Ukraine is a partner an
integral part of the Free World so our
Victory and reconstruction are just
beginning of a long journey and we
understand it for Here We Will and
Ukraine has started like a country that
was a recipient of international Aid and
we were very grateful for the fact that
you provide us with this Aid that help
us to keep the macroeconomic stability
but we are absolutely sure that we will
become a global contributor
we will try to before this conference to
have the internal discussion inside the
Ukrainian government and presidential
office and to develop
nine sectors that we have outlined in
our vision is the key to Ukraine's
transformation
so we are in a 10 10 years we would like
to be
a reliable source of energy for Europe
and one of the leader in the green
industry so second we we think that our
agriculture agricultural sector will be
able to provide food for more than 600
million people ukrainians critical
materials results will become the basis
for the development of high-tech
products
we would become the fastest growing
country in the region
the scale of Ukraine's reconstruction
will be unprecedented
so the development and modernization of
Ukrainian infrastructure will make the
Ukrainian an integral part of the EU
Network and our strong Army and military
industrial complex will ensure Security
in the region on natas eastern border
of course
all this needs Strategic investment and
strategic investors that should come to
Ukraine
the the basis is a trust of our partners
and stability of our country
so of course we understand particular
world that we might must provide the
security
so the business and people can trust
and develop without any fear
no doubt that the biggest guarantee
can be NATO membership
and Ukraine will definitely become a
member and we must ensure access to a
larger markets
and without any doubts access to EU
market with the best guarantee for this
and of course in addition to this we
need to have a comprehensive reform
agenda
the result of which will support
investors at the very stage from the
idea of investing and setting up a
business in Ukraine to successfully
operation in Ukraine we are in a
constant dialogue
with investors and we understand their
needs and are already working on them
investors need smart governance and
clear clear rules of game
as an example just this year the
government has run a competition and
appointment independent supervisor Board
of
state-owned companies like NAFTA gases
we need an enhanced business climate
for uh achieving this aim we have start
a huge deregulation
going through a thousand different
regulations and canceling hundreds
business asks for access to Capital and
clear and competitive fiscal policy here
we're already working on creation of
Ukrainian Development Fund which is
going to provide Equity Capital to many
important investment projects
we also need a modern labor market that
will require
that will
labor market and access to Specialists
and we already start to amend to work
out the amendments to the law so to
provide a comprehensive draft reform
so we are systemically work with the
world's best economists on this issue
and policies to ensure that all these
needs addresses in the Ukrainian
business environment in law regulation
public service
and we are taking the commitments to
transfer Ukraine into the most
convenient and quickest country for
doing business Timothy I was trying as
quick as possible as usual
so much
I I damaged everything
so thanks a lot Julia and um you know I
didn't announce
um Restless love surma from a deputy
head of the Office of the President of
Ukraine because he is so dear to my
heart that I always think you know he's
everywhere so in that sense I just kind
of assumed that he's announced but he
was not so my apologies for that
nonetheless he is not speaking right now
he will be a little bit later uh foreign
secretary please the floor is yours
[Applause]
thank you this is all about adaptation
this is about uh flexibility and
adaptation we're demonstrating that
today
um look thank you for coming here
uh the agenda on this session is a is a
real priority and it is really good to
see that the room is currently over
capacity
um because I think it shows the real
interest that there is and uh I'm going
to start off by saying that our
Ukrainian friends our Ukrainian
colleagues have made notable progress on
reform and transparency all of which
has been done during a period of
incredibly disturbing and trying uh
circumstances
um we've we've we've seen uh speeches
from uh the Ukrainian leadership in the
main plenary session this morning
demonstrating their commitment we've
heard the comments from uh Minister uh
Swan idenko about Ukraine's economic
vision
but we should recognize that reform has
many purposes but all of those purposes
serve to improve government standards
and government Effectiveness now the
primary aim of reform in UK in Ukraine
rather in this instance is to boost
investor confidence and bring in the
money that Ukraine needs for its for its
uh reconstruction
donors need to see progress with regard
to reform and transparency to give the
confidence to keep the flow of
International Investment coming into
Ukraine and of course that's exactly
what Ukraine wants as well
now Wars can devastate both Victors and
losers alike but
they can also strengthen and cultivate a
country's inherent qualities
achieving hitherto
unutilized Advantage years realizing
untapped potential and that is exactly
what we are seeing with regard to
Ukraine
now reform is about transparency it's
about accountability it's about the rule
of law it's about free markets and of
course markets need to be regulated to
keep them free from
manipulation and allow them to maintain
competition and this is the path
that Ukraine has chosen to take and the
UK fully supports Ukraine's decision to
do so and you and the UK has been a
long-standing uh friend and partner in
Ukraine's reform and anti-corruption
journey we've done so for many many
years and I am very glad that through
our partnership but predominantly
through Ukraine's own efforts we are
seeing progress take uh prizoro it's a
procurement system
along with other allies we the UK helped
Ukraine roll this out and it has
generated an incredible saving of
255 million dollars in 2021 alone even
more importantly than that it means that
essential support including food has
been delivered to to war-torn Ukrainian
communities quicker
and more effectively and that 255
million dollars can now be reinvested to
where Ukraine needs it most this is the
prize this is the opportunity I also
want to briefly highlight two projects
that we're delivering alongside uh our
American friends in usaid
the flagship Tapas uh uh project is
building transparency and accountability
into public services in Ukraine we are
putting 12 million pounds into the
project you the US has just increased
its own contribution by over 10 million
dollars the UK and the US have jointly
invested 53 million dollars in Ukraine's
digital transformation since 2016 and
today
Ukraine has the highest ranking in the
eu's latest European open data index
despite
being in 17th Place just two years ago
and we should remind ourselves that
transformation has happened whilst this
country is fighting to defend itself
against Russia's illegal and unprovoked
full-scale uh invasion
that's why we are so proud to continue
working alongside our International
Friends in support of Ukraine
in the U.S and the UK are working
together on state-owned Enterprise
reform as well we put three and a half
million pounds into a project that
reforms or perhaps moves for the very
first time
state-owned assets into private
ownership
supporting projects like this
is why I entered politics and to see it
being delivered in a country uh
defending itself again is quite
remarkable
and I'm sure that's part of the
motivation which sees the United States
adding 20 million dollars to help
support Ukraine's public sector in
Wartime so that they can get the best
value for money from every single penny
spent by the Ukrainian State and today
I'm delighted to confirm the UK's
support ongoing support including 15
million pounds from our good governance
fund and unsurprisingly this does
exactly what it says on the tin it helps
deliver good governance now I could go
on all day about how proud I am of
Ukraine's reform not just on the
battlefield but in their institutions
but there is enough conflict in the
world and I do not want to generate any
more by overstaying my time at the
lectern but
I want to finish by saying this is a
conversation that we need to have it is
not always the easiest conversation to
have but I am genuinely grateful that
ukrainians the Ukrainian government the
Ukrainian leadership has embraced our
friendship in support in this issue
because this will underpin their
recovery in the future
[Applause]
okay good afternoon to everybody
so before going to the specific changes
and the reforms that we plan to do maybe
I would like to quickly remind about why
we are planning to do that I don't see
is it working yeah
so not everybody was at the sessions uh
before so we have very clear Vision what
we want to build in Ukraine in the
economy we want to build these segments
where we have really strong competitive
advantages and where we have the strong
fundamentals behind we obviously see
that this is the energy with this master
investment tickets about perhaps 400
billion I will not stop on that but on
the next session we will deeply
elaborate on this revealing all the
fundamentals all the segments all the
calculations how we arrive to these
numbers the second one is about the
green Industries specifically green
steel and as well in tomorrow's sessions
we'll have a deep dive in the green
steel industry and deep analysis and
competitive advantages
the other absolutely clear stories about
the Agri everybody knows every sector of
Ukraine and we see the huge potential
again of the dozens of billions of
Investments as well will be covered
tomorrow and the same is about the
critical minerals such as lithium
uranium graphite titanium iron and
others and obviously as a result of that
we expect that Ukraine will become a
construction boom country for for a
decade and in total this is all about
the investment ticket for hundreds of
billions but now what we need to do and
change for this to happen there are two
things before we speak about the reforms
that perhaps are much bigger than all
the reforms together the first one is
NATO and the other one is EU why NATO
let's put ourselves in the place of
business would you invest billions now
while you are at the risk of being your
asset fully destroyed obviously we do
implement the war Risk insurance and we
do believe that it will cover the first
projects maybe the first
the first dozen of projects maybe for
hundreds of Millions for billions but we
will not be able to implement such a big
uh such a big program
uh with small risk interest the only and
the best for Risk insurance is NATO the
second one is European union and first
of all about the market of European
Union obviously the Ukrainian recovery
will be a good Market specifically for
the construction for the infrastructure
companies but the main value of all
these segments of all these ideas is
about the access with the competitive
products to the European market now what
homework should we do in Ukraine to make
ourselves competitive the first one
perhaps will be about the law
enforcement agencies and judicial
reforms I think this is perhaps the most
complicated topic because I think nobody
has a clear answer to it let's be frank
there are many road maps many action
plans some of them are being already
fulfilled for two three years but still
we are not yet there but what are the
good signs the good signs I think that
the results for example for the Nabu the
recent case for taking the head of the
Supreme Court of Ukraine at the bribe I
think this is the very Vivid evidence
that the anti-corruption infrastructure
Works in Ukraine because I can hardly
imagine any other country in the world
where as well corruption exists in the
courts where this type of operation
would happen
what we plan to do in the courts
fundamentally we plan to segment it into
two big categories everything which is
immaterial we want to convert to digital
chords
because we have a good track record with
our digital public services and the
course will be one of them as the next
everything which is about material
commercial and administrative courts
will be on the very tough supervision
and Analysis of the fair practices there
in the courts as for the law enforcement
agencies I think
quite quickly just after this conference
you will see the next steps that we'll
take I think it's about the weeks but
finally what we want to implement there
is only one window of communication for
the business there are no four or five
seven agencies that are visiting the
business on the different matters and
the bribes is a result of this contact
there will be only one with the
opportunity to
communicate on all the matters number
two block is about the digitalization
so everybody knows about the progress
that we have done was the DIA and with
the legislation of Public Services we
plan only to enhance the speed of the
public services that we'll provide
because the logic is very simple if
there is no physical contact with the
bureaucrat there is no risk of
corruption and there is one more
important step that I believe that we
will take I cannot tell you definitely
that we will do because it is still
under discussion but under the very deep
and serious discussion about the Holy
team with the president with the Prime
Minister we want to be the first fully
cashless economy we know that there is a
lot of debates about this from the
different stakeholders that we are
eliminating the rights of the people
with no cash but we believe this will be
the very effective tool to eliminate I
think 95 to 99 of all the corruption
cases in the country if there is no cash
at all and I think we come in the
nearest months is with the road map and
with the final decision whether we do it
or not but I believe the decision will
be yes
next item what is important else for the
business the competitive tax system
because I see it representatives of many
multinationals in in this room and when
you plan where to put up your next
facility your next headquarter you check
on the multiple criterias and the tax
rate is one of them so if you want to
compete with our neighboring countries
we need to offer the rates which are in
fact not worse than they offer because
they have many other advantages this is
number one and number two is the system
of communication and administering and
here we'll go back to the full
digitization of the process
the next block which is really important
is about access to finance you could
hardly find the project in any industry
in any company which is funded fully
from the equity of the owners it's
always about the blend the blend of
equity and the blend of loans about
different types of loan product products
that's why we will enhance the increase
the our work with trying to access to
the export Credit Agencies setting up
the Ukrainian Development Fund which
will be running very intensively
together with the BlackRock with
JPMorgan with McKinsey who are now
Consulting us on setting up and on the
accession obviously to the European
Union fund structure funds to build up
different Industries
next month labor market unfortunately
Ukraine has inherited quite post-soviet
regulation for the labor market we plan
to change it quite fundamentally in the
nearest
half a year I think what do we mean
first of all this is the easiness of
hiring and firing people this is about
the model of paying the salaries moving
to the
hourly wages from the monthly salaries
removing the limits for their working
weeks working months because we need to
rebuild the country and we need to
provide the right and freedom for every
person if the person wants to work 60
hours per week to rebuild the country
let him or her work we should not limit
that
next block about the will as you see we
are speaking about liberalizing and
about the free economy but for the free
economy we need to have the strong
regulators and here we three we have
three very important items item number
one is the Anti-Trust unfortunately at
the moment the antitrust agency is not
operating full scale in Ukraine and we
plan to adopt the new law and the
nearest weeks I believe next session or
the one after the next which was
developed together with International
Partners which will provide the true
capacity to the our antitrust agency
number two is the financial Market
regulator the same the law is developed
it's being approved in the Committees I
think there are final five to seven
points that we are still discussing
again it was developed together with the
international partners and I believe
amounts or two it will be fully adopted
and implemented in Ukraine and the
energy sector here we have
finished because the law has been
adopted uh two weeks ago the new
regulator which was fully agreed in
terms of the authority with the European
commission and European energy council
is now in place and physically we'll
build up this capacity I think within
the next months as for the energy
regulator
what is really as well important to
boost the business activities to
eliminate the business the the business
and Market distortions as well we've
done the very bold step on the energy
rates just a couple of weeks ago as you
might know we have increased the rates
for the electricity for for the citizens
for the population two times you can
hardly find any country which has done
this during the war because we have
analyzed multiple cases and I must say
in the 99
the governments have been very
populistic in keeping the rates at the
flat level and not touching them before
the end of the war and we did it
the same have to do for many other
products and we are intended to change
it as well we plan to enhance the excess
of the private Capital to the sectors
which have been traditionally LED and
owned only by the government the sectors
like the education like the health care
like the infrastructure and others
next item privatization
we definitely will go with the massive
and scalable privatization just to
confirm that we have recently just six
months ago started really big
privatization for the small and medium
Enterprises and absolutely digital
models through the prosoro system and
the results have been impressive the
price and the tickets for the same
Enterprise that have been sold that have
been sold before the war during the war
have increased two to three times and
already we have already got since the
half a year during the war more than 5
billion in receipts from the
privatization and we expect that this
number will grow exponentially further
and for those companies that will stay
or government owned or partially
government owned they will full be they
will all be corporators corporatized and
will be structured and the single
Sovereign wealth fund and properly
managed as the holding company
Capital amnesty
we've done an unsuccessful effort
to do the amnesty of capital in Ukraine
just half a year before the war no
result so we think that we'll suggest a
very bold approach of implementing
full amnesty of capital with no
implementation with no exclusions
because we need to mobilize all the
capital that is in the country to
transform and rebuild our country
and perhaps the final page
where we want to win in the competition
every company which considers where to
put the facility again checks
where to do and where to build and
unfortunately we have very few
competitive advantages to our neighbors
and one of them we will believe is the
easiness to build the facility today I
think Ukraine is perhaps the most simple
the the easiest country in the world to
set up legal entity you can do it online
within couple of hours and we want to
repeat the story for the physical
facility and here we break down the task
to four main items the first one is
about land allocation and functional use
of land the draft of the law is ready
and will be submitted to the parliament
in the next weeks the second one is
about the connecting to the utilities
any facility needs electricity gas water
and others unfortunately in Ukraine I
think this is the very weak place
because it's very bureaucratized and
very complicated it will change
fundamentally in three to four months
architecture and municipality approvals
my colleague Alexander kubrakov has
already spoken on that and the law is
already voted which fixes 70 to 80
percent of these issues and I think it
will be soon approved finally and the
residual part will be again fixed within
half a year and the final one is about
the environmental approvals
Unfortunately they are often over
complicate the process for three four
six months as well we plan to liberalize
this substantially
just to summarize we are in time to
fully comply with the European standards
and European rules but we think that for
the transitory period for the Intensive
recovery it may be three five seven
years I think we should have a special
regime special regime for the taxes to
become really competitive special regime
for some of the approval procedures to
become much more liberal than the
typical European standards because we
need to build build and build and the
only bottleneck for these projects
should be the resources and the capacity
of the investor and the Engineering
Process but not the bureaucratic
approvals this is the way that we start
now and then we'll reach our final
Target thank you
[Applause]
and I would like to invite to speak Gary
Kian kupman director general of a
neighborhood and enlargement
negotiations European Commission
thank you thank you very much let me uh
pick up where uh left uh he set out I
think a compelling vision for an
economic growth model uh anchored on two
principles as you said at NATO
membership and EU membership and maybe I
can talk a little bit about what EU
membership or rather working with the EU
eventually becoming a member uh offers
this compelling Vision I think there are
essentially three pillars uh that that
are relevant in this context
first there is a big Market it's the
world's biggest free market and in fact
we have already today
integrated Ukraine to a very large
extent through an unprecedented free
trade agreement that actually no third
country has so Ukraine benefits from an
exceptional series of autonomous
measures giving access to large parts of
the internal market today already
so this is not something that eventually
becomes available when union membership
materializes this is something that is
there today
secondly the process of accession itself
I think can best be understood as
rewriting the software of a country it's
really about modernizing vital processes
essentially aiming at
modernizing the fundamentals of
democracy putting in place good
governance the rule of law
strong anti-corruption practices
respective fundamental rights and also
an economic reform agenda that makes you
fit for an internal Market where free
competition and Fair competition Reigns
Supreme so simply by going through a
process that maybe at First Sight looks
bureaucratic in fact you modernize your
economy and what you've been talking
about in many instances in terms of the
reforms you're undertaking are in fact
reforms that you need to do anyway to
become a member state
so membership is like an economic North
Star for the country and we we know that
our Ukrainian friends see it this way
but we in the commission also see it
this way and as you heard our president
say this morning we will work tirelessly
with our Ukrainian Partners to help them
to become a member by introducing the
necessary reforms we know it is a lot of
work and there are no shortcuts you
cannot cut Corners you actually need to
do all the hard work
uh but what we see and that was the
message uh Mrs Wonderland gave this
morning is that you are embracing this
very energetically uh I cannot uh uh at
this juncture say very much about where
where the commission will come out in
October but what I can say today is that
there is an enormously strong reform
drive across a wide range of uh
important uh uh chapters so the
modernization is starting already today
and is making good progress the third
element is financial support the union
the EU and its member states have
supported Ukraine and uh Ukrainian
refugees of which there are about 10
million in the EU to the tune of 70
billion euros since the start of the war
that I think is the largest support
we've ever offered a third country but
it is totally and utterly Justified
given the horrendous situation the
country faces and the fact that it is
fighting for our European values now
going forward we all know that
rebuilding the country will be costly
and will require sustained reform going
forward and that is why yesterday the
commission proposed a very significant
multi-annual four-year Financial package
of 50 billion euros that not only would
contribute significantly to funding the
state as it re-establishes sound public
finances but also and that's the crucial
message for the private sector here in
the room would create a Ukrainian
investment facility that would
cover Through guarantees many of the
risks that investors would take
as they invest in in Ukraine
that plan will have to be specified in
terms of its Investments and in terms of
its reforms which obviously will have to
be articulated with its European path
and payments under the plan will be
conditional on progress on these reforms
the reason that I'm elaborating it is
that we've just seen the presentation of
a plan and obviously Ukraine can only
have one economic reform plan so we will
be working hopefully with our Ukrainian
Partners in the coming weeks and months
to ensure that the Ukrainian reform plan
the economic plan is also the foundation
for this new instrument and we hope that
the International Community can come on
board and contribute equally to this
plan
now I'm a very optimistic person because
I know that enlargement and integration
in the eu's internal Market Has Lifted
the generation of countries that joined
in the 2000s to levels of economic
Prosperity but Frankly Speaking no one
could have expected at the time all
these countries were growing six to
seven percent not for a few years but
for two decades and some of them now I'm
thinking of some of the Baltic states
the Czech Republic are actually reaching
levels of prosperity that soon will be
above the average in the EU so that is a
message of Hope if the accession process
and the reforms are well managed the
prospects for the country can be
incredibly positive and I think that's a
message investors in the room should
take home and reflect on thank you very
much thank you
thank you very much director General I
see that
disappearing again this time from the
slides behind us you know you're not
there again but it wasn't my doing but
we'll try to get them back on okay
um yeah so so yeah
so so
um we are short on time so we have 17
minutes until the heart stop of the
panel and I was supposed to ask three
questions to each panelist
I just don't have enough time to even
ask these questions
yeah
who can have work yet
so I'm gonna pose an open-ended question
but specific enough that you guys all
can come in
um and the question is
we have just outlined priorities for
reforms in Ukraine for structural and
immediate
and also raised a certain critical
issues notwithstanding the situation in
which Ukraine is
what is missing
or what would you add or do you believe
this priorities what's what's your take
what would you add to this so that would
be my general and question to all
panelists and it just you know volunteer
maybe Stephanie will start with you so
first thank you for the opportunity this
is indeed a very important subject
matter and I think as an investor on the
panel D investor on the panel I need to
speak for the investors and let me start
by saying and everyone has said this but
you know we're looking for a consistent
transparent environment to invest for
the long term and governance and rule of
law really are the critical pieces to
that and as horrible
and horrific as the war is if there is a
silver lining for Ukraine it's that we
now have an opportunity
to help Ukraine get this right
so what does that mean I think very near
term if I were to pick two things that I
think are fundamentally critical to
enticing investment the first would be
recognition of international arbitration
and rules against International
arbitration as they come back into the
country this will give investors a sense
of security that they don't have today
working within the Ukrainian system and
the second and I think it comes back to
what we were talking about about EU
accession and NATO accession we need to
make sure that every single concessional
dollar is tied to what President Van
derlane called today the coordinated
community so everything it's going to
take to join the EU needs to be tied to
that concessional money and it shouldn't
come without that then when I look a
little longer into the medium term we've
talked a lot today about digitization we
heard the Secretary of State blinken Mr
Shermer recommended many people have
been talking about the great work that
the ukrainians have already done the one
thing they haven't said about
digitalization is that it actually
levels the playing field for the small
smes and the large companies at the same
time so the more that we can do to
expand that digitization to allow all
companies to compete equally in the uh
current environment in Ukraine
especially since a great amount of the
early economic growth is going to come
from the smes that will be critical then
I also think that in the medium term and
I think you referenced this um Sherma
but one of the things that we really
need to consider is a separate
Commercial Court and with that several
Commercial Court one appellate court and
if we can consolidate all of that
knowledge one place it will be faster
and quicker to resolve conflicts and to
move companies into bankruptcy and if we
can do that now I think you will really
again be signaling to the International
Investment committee that you're really
serious about reforms and then I think
the last thing and it's been touched on
today but maybe not quite as as much as
I would have liked to see it it's really
the role of civil society and the
private sector together so I look back
at Afghanistan stand and I say to myself
why did 2.4 of the 7.8 billion dollars
that was given to Afghanistan disappear
was because there was no Civil Society
watching over the disbursement of that
money Ukraine has a very deep very rich
civil society that we all need to
continue to support and then tied
together with that as a private sector
which is exactly what we've been talking
about what is the short-term plan and
what is the long-term plan for the
implementation of the reform process
again if you go back to Bosnia
Herzegovina and you ask yourself why did
it fail it failed because the business
sector couldn't see the short and
long-term plan and Civil Society
couldn't track and Trace that long-term
plan and I actually think that the
ukrainians have the opportunity to get
both of those things right as they move
forward and finally I would be remiss to
say that this is not all the
responsibility of the government it also
matters who you do business with I spent
30 years in the IFC before I joined
Citibank and if I walked away knowing
one thing it's who you do business with
so we must make sure that we hold all
the partners who are going to be
investing in Ukraine accountable for
following best practice
all right
thank you very much I'm now going to
turn to you know this rat I guess of all
corrupt officials in Ukraine the
director of the National
anti-corruption Bureau of Ukraine what's
your take are you gonna build the
anti-corruption culture for good in
Ukraine or is it just still work in
progress
in progress actually
but we can keep going
I'm going to speak Ukraine so please use
the microphones
um
[Music]
prosecutions
foreign
[Applause]
you're the chair
of the rice Coalition of Ukrainian Civil
Society organizations
how do you see the role of the
Civil Society in
helping Ukraine become prosperous and
full Democratic during and post-war yes
thanks last but not least Civil Society
thanks for inviting us and giving the
space so Russia tried to destroy
Ukrainian critical infrastructure and
was somehow successful but there is one
component of Ukrainian critical
infrastructure that Russia will never be
able to destroy because it doesn't
understand it it's not existing in
Russia it's Civil Society
single Society was always a foundation
of Ukrainian development and in many
cases was a great partner of Ukrainian
government yeah I'm glad that Mr
cleverly mentions prozoro prozoro is an
exceptional example of how cooperation
between Civil Society government
business and international Partners
brings results so it's a world-class
procurement system that also inspired UK
and I'm happy that UK during the
development of its own procurement Bill
referred to prozoro multiple times and
it was mentioned in parliamentarian
hearings here as well so going forward
we Ukrainian Civil Society organizations
after the war beginning we decided to
unite to support the government of
Ukraine with the future reconstruction
efforts and for us rise is not just a
rise of Ukraine its foundation
reconstruction Integrity sustainability
and deficiencies Integrity is not
possible without transparency and
accountability
and Ukraine before the war was the most
transparent government in the world
official rating obviously War has its
own impact and right now we do have some
limited access to information and open
data and to introduce transparency back
we just have to do whatever we did
before the War Began
moreover we are now working with dream
digital restoration ecosystem for
accountable management and once again
thanks UK for your generous support to
make dream come true
so Dream Will Not only introduce maximum
level of transparency for the
Reconstruction but also will make
reconstruction of Ukraine accountable to
the coral world so every taxpayer who
contributes to Ukrainian reconstruction
will be able to track how every dollar
pound River euro is spent for rebuilding
Ukraine then integrity
integrity
we do have a great infrastructure for
integrity National Agency for corruption
prevention anti-corruption Bureau
Prosecutors Office specialized
anti-corruption court again we just have
to continue doing what we've been doing
we have to strengthen business
institutions we have to protect these
institutions and we have to give you do
the job using all the transparency and
other tools that Ukraine is proud to
have
sustainability
sustainability is about building back
better
and it's pretty complicated you know to
to build back better what is EU green
deal and how to implement it you know
does anyone know I'm sure not it's too
complicated to build back better we need
knowledge we need technology and we need
your support to understand how to
implemented practice so please help us
with these reforms and business please
bring your technology to Ukraine not
just use Ukraine to to rebuild and
lastly efficiency efficiency is about
capability and capacity
we do have some challenges with Ukraine
civil service reform that's something
that we have to protect that something
that we have to strengthen and it's all
about ukrainians who will build Ukraine
so we have to have strong bureaucracy
with Professionals in Ukrainian
government but not only in the central
government decentralization is core we
have to ensure that communities are
capable and have all the capacity and
support So rise transparency
accountability Integrity sustainability
and efficiency these are foundations for
successful Economic Development thanks
thank you very much
thank you so our job today is impossible
because we have to fit uh concluding
remarks and two two or three floor
interventions in the next two minutes
do we have energy
for the floor intervention
okay oh okay good so that gives us two
minutes for the concluding remarks
um we'll start with
Deputy Prime Minister that's what that
says I have to go with you first
you have a mic here
yeah that's that's the mic
that's okay
that's the mic
suppose I would like to
this panel because I think it's the one
of the core panel during this discussion
because we can build up our vision of
what we would like to reach but uh in in
in case if we won't be able to provide
this structural reforms even during the
war time we won't be able to reach it so
that's why uh I think that this
discussion was rather interesting for
the audience as well and uh I think
that's something that uh
was emphasizing it's extremely important
and I hope that we would have the
further discussion
uh so that's why I think that we would
still keep working on all the structural
reforms
that we committed previously and it's
not because we have these commitments
because it's important for us
to provide them as it would make us
stronger and you know we're fighting
we're always emphasize we're fighting
not on the front line we'll fight
another economic front as well so that's
why it's extremely important for economy
to keep running to provide all these
reforms so that's why I was just to say
my my best wishes to all the
participants and I hope that this
conference would be differ from All
Conference on recovery as we might see
the implementation of these things that
we're talking about I think it's
something important we should be focused
on and during the next conference we
would see is there any progress on
something that we are discussing here
thank you thank you so much and foreign
thank you I don't know if
my time microphone is working yes good
um well I I would uh as one of the uh
co-hosts with our good Ukrainian friends
it's one of the co-hosts I'm incredibly
proud that we have this session on the
agenda that it's so well attended and
also the engagement from every element
of Ukrainian uh Society uh is
represented here on the uh on the on the
panel
one of the things that I think was
particularly notable one of the things I
found very reassuring was the Ukrainian
government plan for reform and one of
the things that struck me and I've said
this publicly a number of times over the
last 15 16 months we've seen the
Ukrainian Armed Forces
evolve and improve and modernize and
reform in the midst
of an intense conflict of self-defense
and for me that's a proof point that
when uh the Ukrainian people the
Ukrainian leadership set their mind to a
challenge their ability to deliver
against that is incredibly impressive
and we have now seen a very well thought
through plan of Reform and I think that
gives and should give the confidence for
investors
that Ukraine has a plan not just to win
the war but to win the peace and I think
we all have a duty and an interest in
ensuring they're successful in both so
thank you all very very much
so thank you very much with this uh
let's win the war and win the pins
together thank you very much and we
conclude this fantastic session
[Applause]
so thank you very much was this let's
win the war and win the peace together
thank you very much and we conclude this
fantastic session
[Applause]
right thank you mate
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much was this uh let's
win the war and win the best together
thank you very much and we'll conclude
this fantastic session
[Music]
right thank you mate right
thank you very much was this uh let's
win the war and win the best together
thank you very much and we conclude this
fantastic session
[Music]
thank you
thank you very much
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
we appreciate the proposal of
the Ukraine recovery and reconstruction
guarantee facility for
by the European bank for reconstruction
and development
we also welcome the focus of some
guarantee programs from the EU fund for
sustainable development on Ukraine and
its neighborhood
neighborhood also like to recall that
hand in hand with development of
investment schemes we shall promote the
ability of Ukraine University
[Music]
notably through continuing promotion of
its macro economic stability
we should also work on accessibility of
International Investment products for
small and medium
s and long-term con contacts in Ukraine
and
is
requirements
is now joining countries that have
already decided to start providing
insurance for export to your clients by
establishing its own insurance facility
within the Czech muscles around the
insurance agency which is
by doing so we
saw we have a business is allowing them
to seize the immense potential that
Ukraine offers and we cannot do it along
so much since you wish to all export
print agencies to work instruments and
to work together as soon as possible
very much
thank you very much
[Music]
thank you Minister dear friends and
colleagues
[Music]
but even to imagine the real tone of
Destruction it has caused at all levels
in the tragic scenario the only reality
Spirit of the Ukrainian people
by the many ukrainians
dear friends and colleagues
[Music]
it has caused all levels in the tragic
scenario the only reality that
experience
by the many ukrainians
[Laughter]
[Music]
it is
[Laughter]
easier ideas
decision
communities
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
secretary
[Music]
is
associated
[Music]
so you came
famous
[Music]
eventually
issues
might be a countries
[Music]
businesses without electricity
United States
foreign
[Music]
listen to it